the judge in the case of Donald Trump's
eligibility in 2024 happening in
Colorado turns out to be a donor to the
Democrat uh to Democrats and not just to
Democrats now I love this I think it was
PBS there was a news outlet that said
that there was concern because she had
donated to Liberal groups she donated to
a pack that's specifically trying to
remove Republicans who supported Trump
on January 6th and now she is overseeing
a case where because of January 6
Democrats are arguing Trump is not
eligible to be president so if you
thought this one was going to be fair
surprise surprise now we're hearing that
Minnesota and Michigan are going to have
simal uh similar challenges so that will
be particularly interesting we'll talk
about that plus um oh man you know
normally at this this this stage of the
game I don't really care too much talk
about Ronda sandis but he did he did
Justa on the Patrick Bet uh bet David
value tment podcast where he was called
out for wearing high heels we got to we
got to talk about this story cuz this
one's oh man I think he's wearing high
heels I really do and I think this this
actually you know Patrick Pat David
absolutely uh calls him out and we got a
bunch of other stories uh the US is
building a bigger bomb very very big
nuclear weapon new Gravity Bomb and
we'll talk about that as well as Trump's
being gagged and then um we're going to
talk about this uh hockey story that's
going massively viral that you may have
seen where a hockey player got clipped
in the neck by a skate and it looks like
if you look at the video that the the
other player intentionally kicked him
and this dude died apparently like very
quickly on the on on the on on the in
the ring so we'll talk about that before
we get started my friends head over to
cast brew.com for the best cup of coffee
you've ever had go to cast brew.com
sponsoring the show we've got the
limited edition Halloween special R rise
with Roberto Jr where you can see a
chicken foot coming out of the ground
like a zombie because we are making fun
of our poor dead mascot rest in peace
Roberto Jr but Appalachia kns is my
person personal favorite dark roast we
got whole bean and ground and rise with
Roberto Jr it's our most popular but
don't forget there's Mr Bokus pumpkin
spice experience stand your grounds and
we got K Cups if you want to support the
show you can buy cast brew coffee or go
to
timcast.net individuals and even submit
questions to call into the show and talk
to us and our guests so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel uh
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and a
whole lot more we've got Joey manarino
hello how are you who are you what do
you do it's great to be here I do
political commentary have a podcast
where we do that and that's pretty much
what I do I raise money for campaigns as
well right on is there a campaign you're
working with right now the lady right
next to us who's this lever
Spicer and L would you like to introduce
yourself sure I'm lever Spicer and I'm a
candidate for District 24 in Miami right
on is uh what what are you doing outside
of running for office are you uh
professionally well um 20 plus years ago
I started a food bank after my mentor
died um started a food bank and we
provide food for people that are facing
food insecurity and we feed thousands of
needy families each and every week wow
we help the mothers that are going
through a hard time we give them baby
pampers clothing whever we need so we're
like a One-Stop shop so far as whatever
the community needs we are there to
support those that are really having a
hard time right on and we got Phil and
Hannah clir are hanging out Hannah Clair
I don't know where the camera's are I'm
not sure go ahead you go first I missed
you Phil you're back from California yes
uh I am Phil abanti very failed musician
uh anti-communist uh
counterrevolutionary and Hannah Clair is
here okay and I'm Hanah Clair brimo I'm
a writer for Tim cast.com you should
follow timcast news on the social medias
because it's the best and serge is here
yes I am here uh congratulations guys we
have the cup again and I just want to
rub it in New Zealand's face for once so
yes well all right that's very important
news but uh let's jump to the story from
the New York Times Colorado trial
considers whether the 14th Amendment
disqualifies Trump some constitutional
experts argue that the clause in the
amendment should bar Donald J Trump from
becoming president again but that view
is far from Universal among legal
Scholars now the big story that they're
not getting into in a lot of these
articles one article just said the judge
donated to a li to liberals here's a
here's the tweet from Mike Davis he says
new Denver District Judge Sarah Wallace
a Democrat donor commits reversible
error by refusing to recuse from Trump
January 6th case after donating to
anti-trump January 6 Pack so let's just
get to the specifics here
October 15th 2022 Sarah Wallace donated
to the Colorado turnout project a
political action committee formed to
vote out Republicans who supported Trump
on January 6 2021 and quite literally as
now specifically in Colorado but that's
what they're saying they say we formed
shortly after Colorado Republicans
refused to condemn the political
extremists who stormed the capital on
January 6 in fact Republican rep Lauren
bber even encouraged the violence that's
not true she did not encourage violence
it's absurd but that's what their argu
is and with those lies the judge in this
case has donated to this
organization and is now overseeing the
question of whether or not Trump should
be removed so you know if you thought
there was going to be a fair hearing on
this one you were wrong now it may be
for political reasons the judge can't
just say Trump is off the ballot but
Michigan is next and here's the best
part in Michigan the challenge is not
with Donald Trump someone sued the
Secretary of State saying that Trump
should be removed and when Trump's
lawyers tried to intervene saying like
hey there's no Insurrection here they
said you have no standing you are not
party to this lawsuit now that's a
clever one next up is Minnesota and uh
I'll tell you what I think I think uh
some point next year there is a strong
probability that one state will
unilaterally at the last minute take
Trump's name off the ballot and here's
the important thing I was mentioning
this earlier on the Tim pool Daily Show
My Morning podcast a lot of people are
like yeah but where where where are they
going to succeed with one of these
things right is it going to be a swing
state and then like a Democrat district
judge says you know okay Trump's off the
ball but then the state challenges it
and it's no imagine a state like
California takes Trump's name off the
ballot and then let's say Trump does win
but the but he loses the popular vote by
5 to 10 million votes the Democrats are
then going to say see look Trump he's
how does he win the presidency but lose
the popular vote by 10 million and it's
because in states with massive
Republican populations like California
but they're so heavily Democrat they can
remove his name from the ballot Trump
doesn't get the general Republican votes
in the a decent amount and then it looks
like Trump did not actually win the the
popular vote because they removed him
that's another game they might play but
I'm curious what uh what y'all think all
you need is one state if you get one
state you have precedent and then the
other ones can go and follow suit if
they do that I mean we're we're so third
world at that point the fact that this
is even being considered this judge
should be thrown off the case you donate
to a pack that is focused they're only
focused on bobert in Colorado but
they're actually focused on everybody
with the mentality that Trump won the
election anybody that's Maga they want
out well she donated money to it she
should be thrown so far off the case she
says that she doesn't remember I mean
that's the quote that Colorado Public
Radio is running with that she donated
$100 and her justification was well I
don't remember making that donation and
I didn't know what their uh the mission
of this organization was well she's too
stupid she needs to fix it doesn't seem
like a great judge right this is
questionable all
around I think that's the point though
like the the the the substance of the
case doesn't really matter it's
obviously that they're after Trump
they're looking at for any excuse they
can come up with so I mean I don't have
a whole ton to add just because it's
it's blatant and clear and the idea that
the American public accepts it is
probably the most the thing that I have
the most problem with is the is not just
that this is happening it's that people
are so disengaged and uninterested or
you know comfortable with this type of
behavior it means that the the
fundamental uh ideals that our country
are founded on people don't have any
respect for him at all anymore no
massive protests out there no nothing
nobody's even talking about I think you
have to give credit to uh Jason Miller
who's with the Trump campaign who was
the one who was like this is happening
this judge donated to this cause and
it's one of the only quotes that I have
seen circulated at all I mean this
detail that she has donated that she is
essentially a biased judge from the
beginning and we know about it and and
she was the one to decide well I'm not
going to accuse myself is crazy and I
think this is the type of case that
they'll just try over and over again
until something sticks and if it's not
this if they run out of 14th Amendment
arguments they'll shift to another claim
against Trump look so look uh Trump's
lawyers argued if they're even going to
pursue this argument Trump has to have
been convicted under the federal statute
pertaining to rebellion and Insurrection
specifically created to deal with the 14
Amendment and he has not been they're
doing it anyway and and already the
judge said no it doesn't matter we can I
I think she should recuse herself from
this case and when it comes to him it's
like justice is blind they do whatever
they want to do nobody is protesting
nobody is fighting against it or
anything it's time for people to stand
up and stop being afraid we got to stick
together we got to fight through this
because if they could do that to him
then which one of us is next oh worse
than that right what they can do to
Trump they can do to you tfold uh-huh
they just come and shoot us in the head
the New York Times says judge Wallace
has laid out nine topics to be addressed
the trial which is scheduled to last all
week they include whether section three
of the 14th amendment applies to
presidents what Enga what what engaged
and Insurrection mean under that section
whether Mr Trump's actions fit those
definitions and whether the amendment is
self-executing in other words whether it
can be applied without specific action
by Congress identifying whom to apply it
to so the 14th Amendment Section 3
specifically say
representative or me or member of the
Senate it specifically says elector of
the president or vice president and then
it says uh and may not hold office civil
or military and so the argument people
are making is that the reason why
Section 3
outlines the the exact elected positions
and then says civil office is because it
views them it views a distinction civil
office meaning a bureaucratic job you're
appointed to whereas the other positions
you're elected to so it would seem their
arguments is oh Trump can be president
because president isn't specifically
addressed here but that's that's a tough
question because I don't know civil
office by I'm not going to sit here and
say the silly argument from the from the
left they say you know a well-regulated
militia means government regulation when
it's not what regulated mean meant back
then back then regulated meant like well
equipped and and and properly armed with
clean materials and so perhaps civil
office meant something specific back
then it doesn't mean today I guess we're
going to hear but but regardless of this
I think it's absolutely silly to be
having the the hearing at all yeah the
fact that when it came to 2020 the
majority of the lawsuits coming from
Trump were dismissed on standing and not
the merits right and then you see a case
like this where there's literally no
merit whatsoever but they hold it Anyway
come on legal system is is is well I'll
put it this way I'm not I'm not so
convinced as to say the legal system is
completely broken but Republicans don't
file lawsuits anyway so we wouldn't know
no we just sit back and get destroyed
every single time we're weak and we let
them run all over us you're talking
about definitions they don't care about
definitions they write the rules they
rewrite them if they don't work for them
they don't care we make the third world
look like beautiful right now what
they're doing to us it's ridiculous so I
I don't think we stand a chance against
this kind of stuff unless we get smart
and get smart quick as long as as long
as Ron McDaniel is running the she
should be fighting this what's she doing
getting more Botox or something it's a
joke it is it is unconscionable that not
only is she still in her position but
Donald Trump was talking positively
about her just the other day and I don't
know what is wrong with that man to to
not see that two elections were run
absolutely horribly the Democrats
absolutely outworked the Republicans
they made the Republicans look like
fools and it was sign the significant
portion of it was ground game I believe
that that Donald Trump would have won in
2020 had it not been for the Republic an
being so bad at their job because they
let the Democrats do uh change the the
laws in in no pania they were in on it
in Pennsylvania the Republicans teamed
up with Democrats to change the rules in
violation of their own Constitution well
and Ron McDonald knows and Trump knows
this too that the RNC needs Trump I
don't believe Trump knows things I think
I think Ian we have to look back at the
debate right Ron mcdal puts out this
first statement being like it would be a
mistake to miss the debate this is a bad
idea but they know they need Trump to
bring in the viewership that's how they
are going to generate money off this
fundraising right every fundraising
email is get your Trump gold card and
then you look at the bottom and it's
always the RNC the r that that's money
doesn't go to trump it goes to her and
her sick people around that place they
know they need him on so many levels and
I wish that Trump would do more to hold
him accountable to that they need him so
much more than Republicans on the state
level need the RNC to be better at
organizing I don't know that Trump's
supporters who you know would follow him
into a burning building necessarily
would turn out for every single person
he endorses on with the same enthusiasm
and that's actually what the RNC needs
to get get serious about in my opinion
you've been on campaigns longer than I
have yeah it's just a lot of times the
RNC just ignores the campaign you see
people I think you're going to have J.R
majusi on later this week he got screwed
by these people I mean they don't take
the time to actually work with the good
candidates they work with the candidates
that going to be meable to what they
need them to do which is go with the
status quo go along with what gets along
kick back your money to us so that we
have our funded operation it's all a
money game and it's all a joke it's like
the GOP is in competition with the
libertarian party for the most useless
party in America yeah it is ridiculous
and I think there's just a cultural
misunderstanding I think you know they
are definitely not the counterculture
anymore but for all the years the DNC
said we're the oppressed ones we're the
counterculture come volunteer with us be
active with us I mean it did translate
into people who are willing to knock on
doors and to be more active on a
Grassroots level RNC says grabs TRS but
I don't think it actually has strong
organizations and I know the argument
you know rural versus whatever I don't
think that it's about that I think that
it's I think that the temperament of
people that are conservative it's harder
to get them to be activist types um I
think that you see people that are that
are progressives or or that are upset
with the status quo it's far easier to
motivate people like that to get out and
and get a do things you know have a
ground game be activist the the people
that are that are Republicans or
conservatives that tend to be kind of
activists they tend to do things with
with like their church or whatever
whereas the left it's it's homeless
shelters and you know food not bombs and
and you know that kind of stuff too I we
have risks like you know you go out and
you put yourself out as a conservative
you live in an urban area she can tell
you she gets more death threats than
anyone I know it it's ridiculous what we
go through so we can't run around all of
us don't have The Bravery to say yeah
I'm a conservative yeah I'm going to go
organize no you might get really hurt
well I think that's the problem is that
conservatives tend to be cowards yeah
well not this one cuz last year anytime
every day I'm very vocal very bold and
I'm out there and what I saw last year
from a lot of candidates that really put
their heart out there their soul gave it
everything they had ran on that American
first platform we got like no support
from the party that is that is
unconscionable and it's not a surprise
you look at people like uh Scott
Pressler who's probably the most
effective conservative uh activist when
it comes to actually getting people to
vote and getting people registered and I
I can't understand why the RNC and Rona
McDonald's aren't like giving this guy
every every single bit of help that they
could possibly muster for him he's
effective I think it's twofold though
they'd have to admit that they are doing
something wrong and they need him and
there's an ego and pride there they
don't want to but also the RNC you know
has its own behind the- scenes politics
I think about when Larry Elder
challenged Gavin Newsome in the recall
right and the RNC even though he emerged
as the leader the RNC did not give him
the support they should have right and
theoretically that is one of the most
important and I think under talked about
political battles that we had in recent
history and the RNC did not even give
him the fighting support that he needed
in my opinion uh there is a disconnect
between what the voters want and what
the administrative size of that wants I
mean it is sad but you know to your
point they ultimately know where the
money is they know what supporters
that's why they invoke Trump's name when
it's convenient to them and they like to
be in the opposition because you raise
more money if you can send an email that
says we're being screwed they're going
to kill us all we're destroyed the
Biden's ruining us than if you talk
about results and it's sad but it's true
it's infuriating because that that
ineffectiveness and that desire to be
the underdog is part of the reason why
the whole of the culture is so run by
the left and it translates to all the
anti-Semitism and stuff that's going on
in in college campuses now if the
Republicans gave people something to
Aspire to the Republican party I mean if
they gave people something to Aspire to
you wouldn't have the left dominating
everywhere in our society and the left
does dominate every Institution in our
society right now and it's starting to
have realworld consequences and you're
seeing it in the you know case in point
the all the anti-Semitism and all the
people that hate the Jews and stuff that
that you see in college campuses Le I'm
curious what your experience is as uh a
conservative I mean were you always a
republ how did you get to where you are
well like I said with the food bank I
always had to be vocal get out there
roll elbows with the politicians so what
caught my attention and I'm going say it
again I always say it for so far as
myself and so many other black
conservatives was that when Trump said
in 2020 why don't y'all run and take
back your community because they're not
helping you anyway so that's what caught
my attention and that's when I decided
to change and become a
conservative and did your community
react positively negatively I mean did
other black conservatives decide they
they would support you well it wasn't I
didn't really care if they supported me
or not you know I don't give a damn
about that but um so what really I think
that so far as my community you know
they don't give a damn cuz they know
when they need to help they can come to
me I'm in the streets I'm with the
homeless I'm with anybody that's hurting
in need to help I'm there but um the
community supported me but it was just
um you know with the Twitter page people
start coming after me calling me all
kind of derogatory names and um you know
the coons the and everything else that
come along with that and uh you know I
guess they most of them didn't know
exactly who they was talking to but they
quickly found out I like that response I
think that's really funny cuz I think
they thought I was going to be afraid
you know because they called me all the
ugly names that that would run me away
from the party so no let's uh let's jump
to this from Newsweek and we we'll get
silly uh I saw this earli today Patrick
Bet David was interviewing Ronda santis
and I was uh I was really surprised I'm
consistently impressed with uh Patrick B
David's ability to get some of these
personalities on his show he had um
Anthony Weiner now he's got Ronda santis
you know we've got two people who do
booking for timcast and these people are
terrified but I don't even go I don't
even think I go as hard as Patrick B
David does but people really want to be
on his show so we got we got to we got
to learn a lessons from pbd he knows how
to handle this take a look at this story
from Newsweek Ronda santis addresses
rumors that he wears lifts in his boots
okay let me just play the clip from the
show dude ah I got to play it's a minute
long here we go I'm sure your marketing
team points out how they're trying to
troll you in the marketplace okay I'm
sure they're doing that can you bring
this one clip I know you were on uh uh
uh what do you call it on uh uh what was
it Bill Maher and Bill Maher talked
about the boots I've seen you walk with
these boots go and play this clip this
on Tik Tok went viral it doesn't have a
million views it doesn't have you know
10 million views this thing's got 1.2
million likes and and some people are
wondering H what are they I don't even I
haven't seen that what they're they've
not shown this to you okay what they're
trying to say with this is that in your
boots you have
heels no no no those are just standard
off the rack um liuy um how tall are you
how tall are you Governor how tall 5'11
okay why don't you wear tennis shoes
shoes and dress shoes uh I do wear
tennis shoes when I work out yeah okay I
got a gift for you I'd love for you to
wear okay I shop at ferl okay
and I got I don't accept gifts I can't
accept it I'm sorry oh man I his like
immediate reaction 511 I I'm sorry I
think Ronda hand is wear high heels and
I just want to shout out I think Ashley
stclair may have just driven the final
nail into the disantis campaign coffin
yeah this he's he's not going to recover
from this and I'm not even I'm not being
sarcastic or hyperbolic at all he is not
going to be the president and this is
this is like his I think the GU name was
yeah the dean moment because I
mean the the honesty is like the the
truth is if you're like below 6 foot
you're not going to be the president
people talk about oh half the presidents
have been you know under 6 foot and half
of them were over but how many since the
Advent of Television have been under 6
foot I still think 5'11 is the height
men give when they know they're not 6
feet or not me well you know they're not
six feet but they can't like officially
they want to pretend they're a little
taller so it's like well I'm 5'11 like
no no no they're actually like 5'8 and
like no that's not bad I wish he would
just own it right well no I mean he he
he could own it but he's not but he's
not going never going to be the
president if you're that if you're not
if you're not tall can you imagine he
went from being the governor that was
the of Freedom the governor that was
basically next up in line if he would
have waited till 2028 he would have
probably been the Republican nominee and
now instead we're sitting around here
talking about does he wear high heels
his best hope is to like get an
Instagram sponsorship with a heal
company this is what happens I don't
know that I believe I don't know that I
believe that he ever would be able to be
the president just because of his height
I I strongly believe that if you're
not accepting Society no that doesn't
count that doesn't no that doesn't count
stop that doesn't count for men that is
not the truth for men at all but without
Trump in the race will we even be
talking about it Trump is the one who
put his people on this this is a trump
that we you know nobody cared about
these things necessarily it doesn't it I
he would get on stage and be next to
someone taller and that's all it would
take okay because I don't think that I
honestly don't believe that there is a
situation where people are going to look
at like dudes on stage on behind a
Podium and if one is significantly
taller than another they're not going to
vote for the short guy they're just not
going to do it you know we believe in
you guys come on I pulled up a bunch of
photos just looking at my phone of uh
from way before s was running for
president and I just looked up photos of
trump uh Trump with the santis and he
looks like he's probably
5'11 unless a fake height no men are
5'11 they're just pretending to be 51
unless he's been wearing high heels the
whole time which is possible and then no
one noticed until now I I imagine that
he probably did he probably wore him as
soon as he it's probably been for a
while as soon as he started dating may I
mean if he's wearing him now it's
something that he's been concerned with
we need to get a picture from when he
got married because he got married in
his dress uniform which might be harder
to hide lifts in and then we can do a
comparison to the objects around them
that's my new theory that that photo is
amazing he's floating into the sky this
is what a lot of people said about this
picture right here that his
uh like they think he's wearing these
fake shoes otherwise he's got really
long legs halfway to the one that's like
there's no way any human has this length
of bone except for Ronda santis yeah
someone said to sanz's heels are so high
it looks like he's being photographed
mid Rapture MH I just think if he had
respond Photoshop I don't know I just
wish he had responded to this more
positively embraced it with humor
because it would have been a different I
don't know that it would have changed
his campaign completely but it would
have given him the personality that
right now people critique him for not
having right humorless he's lifeless
that's the problem this was this perfect
moment to do something and I'm just sad
they didn't embrace it right I'm not
trying to make him feel bad about his
height you know I I he can be any height
he wants to be apparently but it doesn't
have to be like this and they made it
this weird sticking point that now
people are always going to try and bring
up I don't I I mean I still strongly
feel like only have a tall president I
guess if I it's not about it's not about
it's about the way that people
unconsciously react it's it's it's not
something that people are going to be
able to identify on their own going to
say they'll just be like I don't know
the other guy just looks more
presidential it'll be he's more
commanding I he's I trust him and that
it's a deep part of human psychology all
about yeah it is all about Charisma and
when it comes to men taller men are
looked at as an authority that is just
the way people react that is not
anything no one thinks about it at all
it's attractive privilege is all it's
100% attractive privilege and that's the
way that it P pans out for men with
women if you're a if you're if you're a
large woman you're not as attractive as
smaller petite women that's just reality
I'm not trying I think it's even Beyond
attractiveness I think you know some of
this stuff that we look for to to
indicate Health well-being that are deep
in our psychology that you know they
young and vibrant height is one of them
I mean even babies in you know tiny
newborn babies prefer symmetrical faces
there is something deep in our minds
that looks to seek for indicators of
health or strength or whatever it is uh
I just think you know maybe he could
never have been president but I just
think the way his team handled this was
how tall is the demented guy in the
office right now Mr abiden how tall is
he he's 6 feet wow okay imagine if Ron
just said well I can't accept the gift
but I can try him on and then stood up
and put him on you got to get out of the
lifts they're probably tough to get out
of though well then cuz the the thing
about it is that uh this clip this image
right here man it's like the third time
we've talked about this uh the front of
his foot looks like it's smashed up
against the boot up against the boot
like it's really tight on his foot
there's a a clip from an old late night
show when Jake Gyllenhaal people are
like how tall is he and so he just takes
off his shoes and they measure him on
the set of whatever a generic late night
show it is and he comes up less than six
foot maybe 5'11 maybe 5'10 and he just
sort of nods along and laughs with it
and then it that that question just dies
away no one asks that anymore uh and I
think making this into sort of an
internet meme is way worse it's terrible
it just makes him look like a joke it
makes him look insecure I outside of
this Patrick Bet David asking him the
question was a tremendous opportunity to
end it and he doesn't have the Charisma
to to do that his his his respon is well
first of all the fact that he's never
seen it but that's a lie he's seen it
probably cries himself to sleep watching
it but that's just that's just the thing
he he should have been like oh I've seen
this clip I've seen this clip yeah it's
a good one it's not real but instead
he's like what I've never seen this he's
like You' never seen no then you got a
terrible PR team that's not actually you
know I I wonder if it it's true he
really he really has never seen it which
would make it seem like his PR team is
like he's so insecure about his height
we have to hide it from him that's not
great either he hired the worst possible
people in Communications imaginable who
took the front runner to the bottom yeah
if you're the Pres if you're running for
the office of President and you don't
think that image is important you're
going to lose period you have to
understand that half the that most
people make their decision about you
with their gut they think about it they
rationalize their their their emotional
reaction after the fact that's just the
way human beings work if you don't
portray yourself in a charismatic way
the reason people love Trump is because
he's charismatic in a way that's
attractive to them and that's also the
thing that some people find repulsive
nobody likes Trump because of his
policies because Trump doesn't have any
policies the policies are going to
change depending on the last person he
spoke to no one no one well hold on hold
on that's true no no no his policies
changed depending on what Tucker Carlson
said that night fair enough okay
depending on what Tucker car but but to
be fair there's that Tucker Carlson
anchor on on Trump you know what I mean
I mean I think that Tucker Carlson puts
thought into his Pol into the policies
that he would or would not back I don't
think Trump does I think Trump is is
just driven by his gut see but we can
forgive stuff that Trump does because of
we can't forgive the santis cuz I mean
he's like a lump on a log it's just it
doesn't work and Trump has proven that
he's tall because Baron is like what 600
tall that's the comparison put the
santis next to
Baron never way it's going to be Trump
trump 2024 Baron as VP and he's just
like 10 feet tall at this point
everyone's just like his like knees
don't fit under the desk he's just so
enormously tall Bar's going to be the
first emperor there there's a lost known
uh uh uh um uh Statute in the
Constitution that says you have to be at
least 35 president or at least 10 ft
tall at least and baron Trum is like I'm
on my way Baron's qualified y this is
well that's uh that's your Presidential
news outside of uh uh Donald Trump we
just skipped over Pence dropping out
over the weekend we're
like boots that's how boring the puns
campaign has been when I we were hanging
out in Pittsburgh and I'm like I look at
my phone it's like Mike Pence has
dropped out and I was like oh and I hit
retweet and I was like what were we
talking about again I think what were we
eating I think we had uh what did I have
for for dinner I Thai food thai food I
said it to my more interesting than
Pence yeah I said I told my step I was
like oh Pence dropped down she's like
didn't he already do that he's running
what he dropped out January 6 2021 in to
be to be fair to be fair you know even
the fact that we're making fun of Ronda
STIs is better than Nikki Haley she's
just I don't she's in second place and
is is a lump is a lump on a log she's
loved by a certain crowd though over 60y
olds they absolutely love this woman and
it's it's this old war mentality this
old America has to be in charge in the
police state you know and all that stuff
well someone's got to blow up these kids
right that's that that's the ne I want
toart Department of offense not defense
she said that yeah she said I'm on a
department of offense you go fight woman
I mean that was a joke I made a long
time ago to my friends that we don't
have a Department of Defense we have a
department of offense and all my
anti-war buddies are laughing and now
she's just coming out and saying it so
who she want to go to war with everybody
you name the country I mean fair enough
war with Italy if she
could but I just I don't see I I mean
currently there's there's the argument
that Iran is is funding Hezbollah and
that it's possible that there be kind of
Engagement but that is pretty far down
the road still and I don't think that
it's a direction that we should be
trying to go the the the American people
have no desire to go to war with Iran at
all American people don't have an
appetite for war right now right now
American people don't want to go to war
with for anything no we just want to
fund for Country UK everywhere El you
imagine they send our people to fight in
Ukraine our soldiers to fight a war in
Ukraine well they've already deployed
thousands to for the war in ukra disg
and we have special forces there these
are lives of people they don't
understand that part now I guess
Ukraine's kind of fallowing the back
burner zinsky is the you know he's
yesterday's news back on seeking
Arrangement looking for a new sugar
daddy that's right that's right I think
that the the the war in Ukraine is has
been basically decided you okay down
there no this is so funny it's
true I I mean I don't think that anyone
that's serious believes that Russia is
going to give up of the territory that
they've taken and I don't see any reason
why the US should keep giving money to
Ukraine I don't think Russia's looking
to take more territory in Ukraine either
if they if if the ukrainians and the
Russians can say okay this is it I think
that that it could they could have have
some kind of ceasefire there would have
to be there's going to be new new
borders drawn and that's just the way
it's going to be zinski doesn't want
that he would we'd have to stop paying
him so much money well nobody fun for
him the US doesn't want that either cuz
they'd have to stop laundering money
through not going to launder itself
that's so true everybody's making a
killing on this war and I hate to say it
the best thing that could happen would
be Russia wins and we don't have to deal
with Russia did win because if if
Ukraine rebuilds guess who's rebuilding
everybody in here is tax dollars just
Russia Russia won yeah you're right the
the it's it's fascinating if you look at
the start of the war and the territory
gained by Russia mhm and the argument I
get from uh uh more establishment
conservative types is no no Russia
wanted the whole country yeah sure like
no wanted the land bridge to Crimea like
that's what we've been saying non-stop
now they have it and now nothing's
changed there's no advancing it's just
locked and Russia got what they wanted
yeah and we'll never know when it really
ends because the money laundering would
stop so this will go on into the next I
mean well no I think I think it'll
likely end um because Israel's firing up
true that's a good point they got to
figure out just how to launder it right
through there and we'll be good yeah
once they get the bank accounts all set
up I don't think we should be sending
any more money to Ukraine when we have
people right here in the United States
that are suffering and cannot afford to
pay their rent and staying and sleeping
in the streets amen yep it's as simple
as that isn't it sure is but for some
reason you get Mitch McConnell what what
did he say the biggest priority was
funding fing Ukraine he should go over
there he can have his little strokes in
the next to zalinski wow he Lindsey
Graham deploy them first I mean that's
the craziest thing at least Nikki
Haley's husband is actively deployed
right now he's in Africa but you know
she there is willing to send her own
husband to war it's a bold choice on my
opinion but you know uh all of the
politicians who call for funding for war
want to send your children and your
siblings and your cousins they don't
want to go themselves and they don't
want anyone they actually know or are
related to to go I think Lindsay just
likes the war stuff because it makes
them look more masculine and we all know
what's going on there oh I I think these
people are just funded by uh massive
multinational corporations in the
military industrial complex and so
they're going to go on TV and warmonger
100% well let's uh let's jump to this
story from deadline Joe Biden talks
about watching an AI generated deep fake
of himself I said when the hell did I
say that so apparently Biden wants to
launch some AI safety regulations and
guidelines and things like this they say
uh President Biden signed an executive
order on AI billing the us as outfront
of other countries when it comes to
establishing guard rails around the fast
emerging technology but Biden told those
gathered in the East room that other
steps will require congressional action
that will be a much more complicated
process as long lawmakers have been in a
stalemate for years when it comes to any
meaningful action on Tech Giants
speaking to reporters after the White
House ceremony Senate Majority Leader
truck Schumer said that all this that
his effort to craft a bill this is about
the hardest thing I have attempted to
undertake legislatively because it is so
complicated because a it's so
complicated B it affects every aspect of
society Schumer said that he and the
rest of the bipartisan group of
lawmakers will meet with Biden on
Tuesday to talk about the legislation I
think we're in a post legislation uh era
of this country y I don't think
legislation is going to get passed
unless it's nonsensical and irrelevant
or or jammed into an omnius and uh when
it comes to major issues like AI it's
just going to happen and no one's going
to do anything about any of it so you
look at where the internet is today and
kids have access to adult content and
nobody cares in fact there are
Libertarians who argue they should it's
the parents fault and I'm like well I
guess it's like saying it's parents
fault of a kid sneaks if a kid goes to
an adult bookstore and the guy lets him
in I think at a certain point there is a
shared responsibility between the people
granting the access and the parents were
supposed to be watching their kids with
that being said AI stuff is just going
to keep happening there's not going to
be any regulation and it's going to get
wild and then that's it there you go
you'll live in the pot you'll eat the
book and China is going to control it
all
yep I feel confident that China whether
or not the us passes some kind of
restrictions because Mark Mark andreon
is uh frequently talking about doing
some kind of limit on he really wants to
Full Stop on AI research because he
thinks that it can get out of hand real
fast but I think that that doesn't
really matter because it's not going to
be something that the whole world is
going to abide by even if then you know
us companies or companies that had a
large portion of their business done in
the US even if they committed to
stopping that doesn't mean China's going
to stop and and I don't think that China
is as Cutting Edge as the US is but I
think that they would be or they will be
quickly if the US stops develop if us
firms and companies stop developing I
mean right now Google's as much of the
the military industrial complex as Ron
is like they're the they are exactly the
same type of of you know involvement
with the with the Warfare State and the
surveillance state so there's no
incentive for these companies to
actually stop no matter what the the the
president passes or executive order he
says I I just don't see it happening
yeah and for me part of the danger with
AI is that it's marketed as just
something fun that we try out and play
right now I mean every time you get
access to to uh you know Photoshop just
unveiled a tool that uses AI so you can
use AI to generate things but that is
refining the AI the more exposure the
more people use it the more essentially
free beta testing they have for it uh
the more complicated of a a tool it
becomes to unravel and I just don't
think that and look I openly identify as
a boomer in terms of Technology but I
just don't think there's any way for the
people who are legislating to legislate
effectively and fively enough to be
ahead of this we're already behind it
that's why we're trying to play catchup
uh and I certainly don't know anyone who
can effectively talk about the
ramifications of AI in a way that would
eventually make it into an effective law
half of them can't even open an email
and they they're the people that are
going to do ouri some democratic some I
think it was one of the democratic
congressmen from North Carolina he used
to do Tik toks from the capital and he
was like today I met with you know the
head of Technology at the capital to get
my laptop and he dead Pann asked me if I
needed him to show it needed help o
learning how to open the laptop and
learning how to launch an
email basically stayed dead for months
so it's just it's ridiculous and these
are supposed to be our leaders the
executive order uh is going is basically
going to direct the Department of
Commerce to develop standards for
authentication and watermarking
impossible yeah they'll make the
standard it'll be exploited by them
that's what they'll do they'll make a
standard and they'll say this label
certifies a video organic and then
they'll just charge companies for that
organic uh label yeah so you're going to
be a news organization and you're going
to go to this system and you're going to
be like we're going to upload the video
we're going to certify it and then
they're going to stamp it and then
you're going to pay your your monthly
fee or whatever or your license per per
content fee just like if you were uh
getting other government stamps on your
product or if you're an independent
journalist and you take video on the
ground what's to stop anyone else from
saying oh no this doesn't have the right
certification or you didn't upload it
correctly or we have questions about
this so now we're going to lock down
your content because we think it
potentially could be AI generated based
on literally nothing other than we don't
really like what you're filming I mean
it's it's not that I don't want there to
be regulation I think AI is I'm fearful
of it but it's just hard to think of a
way that would be effective and not open
a whole bunch of other problems right
you're
right anyways I can r on I'll just
continue to talk about why I'm scared of
AI okay here we go no I mean this is the
thing I've had other people suggest to
me that when I'm doing research for
articles that I should turn to J chat
GPT and like ask it questions and chat
GPT can be an incredibly effective tool
but I was just sitting with someone in
the office who was using it to double
check a math equation and chat GPT got
it wrong and so you just can't trust
that the AI intelligence is actually
reliable right I mean it eventually will
develop its own agenda I do not trust it
I don't care what Elon says I'm not
convinced that AI will ever be creative
because currently AI is is a essentially
it can only know what's on the internet
now it doesn't come up with any ideas of
its own so I don't and I'm I'm not in
any position to make an authoritative
statement about AI uh but I am skeptical
that it could be creative in the way
that human beings are sure but I imagine
you know once once it reads every book
and listens to every song it's going
it's already at that point where it
knows what people like and then can make
pop music granted if you want to make
art music sure weird experimental and
weird sounds it could certainly do that
just increase the instability in the in
the algorithm and then it'll output
something a little bit weirder so I
don't I don't know what creativity is
going to mean in that context when I say
creativity I'm I'm more thinking in cre
not so much creative like art style or
or musically but like creative as in
like Innovations in fields like I don't
think the AI is going to figure out how
to do cold fusion I disagree I think it
will you think you can figure out cold
Fus because I my my impression is that
without the without the the information
already being there I feel like it it
wouldn't be able to come up with
Innovations was that so it's like sodoku
so they've uh the periodic table for
instance per periodic table of elements
when it was first made there was like
huge gaps in it and they were like
there's probably something there based
on this already and then we're filling
it in and we're like whoa there's like a
whole section here and so what I think
it's going to be like a sidoku puzzle
once enough data is plugged into the AI
it's going to spit out hey guys see
these things right here there's there's
a particle there a particle there
there's an element there we're going to
be like wow we could not see these
things and then it's not going to know
it's going to say based on all of the
pieces laid out I'll put it this way
we're loading all the puzzle pieces of
this 50 billion piece jigsaw puzzle into
this machine and then it's sorting them
and then showing us the picture and
we're like there's huge gaps in where
there should be things here now we know
pieces are missing we know what to look
for but it's but it's also going to be
able to uh predict what those pieces are
going to be especially on like you know
things like elements for instance and
and particles and and permutations of
various compounds or whatever it's going
to be able to be like this you know I
remember watching these old movies where
the scientist like inputs into the
computer you know a formula and then
presses enter and then it's like formula
unstable and I'm like what how's the
computer know I'm like oh back then
probably not but today yes oh yeah
you'll be able to input a sequence and
then it'll tell you like here's what
will happen if you it's gon to know much
more than we can think it's going to
really advance I think exponentially
very fast and yeah it's going to be a
very very quick transition within 10
years it's going to be really Advanced I
don't think 10 years you think even
faster than that even faster than that
because when the singular when the
singularity happens it will be instant
if it's faster it's to it's scary cuz
they'll use it against us somehow you
know it always starts good against us
yeah it's going to be a tool that's
going to end up probably destroying us
like everything else ends up being we
said Alexa even Alexa was so good
Alexa's reporting people to the cops but
that's why I I never understood the dra
Alexa because it's always listening that
seems like like you bug your own home on
of many crimes has Alexa turned in their
owners for it's ridiculous and they
allow yeah I know a few people who got
caught on I don't know them personally
but I see them on you can subpoena the
recordings from Ala the first thing you
should do is get those things the hell
out of your house it's craziness it's
craziness I had a boss who was like
we'll put them in every office and I was
like I have to leave this job I that
everyone should understand that if if
you have concerns about Alexa you should
make sure you shouldn't have a
smartphone either no you need to keep
that we should all move to the woods and
the mountains I mean this is the hard
thing which is that I understand some
technology is really valuable and can
change the lives of people Advanced
business this that and the other but
ultimately what are we sacrificing to
pay for right all these things
especially again I go back to sort of
the free access to AI or you know
lowcost access to some AI programs that
are essentially uh allowing you to test
AI out and it's testing you out there is
a cost and we're not going to know it
until it's too late and that's what I'm
fearful of Y I have uh Alexa in my
apartment but I don't have Alexa in my
uh at my house in in New Hampshire why
would you have it in your apartment Phil
because it's just the apartment it's not
the house in New Hampshire you crazy
it's not the Fortress of Solitude you
should protect all of the fortresses
even your your satellite office here in
West Virginia the apartment is not is
not a uh a fortress so you can talk to
your dog when you're gone is that what
you're saying no a little bit no no not
at
all let's just jump to this wild story
here this is uh this this was the big
story of the day so uh you know we can
talk about a lot of news Donald Trump's
being sued but the story that was
sweeping across the internet from human
events British police open investigation
into death of hockey player Adam Johnson
who was killed by opposing players skate
blade uh simple version of the story a
dude got his throat slit by a ice hockey
skate and then bled out in the ring died
presumably very very quickly I mean
there's video of it it's it's horrifying
however they the media kept calling this
a freak accident over and over again and
then when the video came out it looks
like this dude Matt petgrave raises his
leg to kick the other guy and uh there's
video of it I don't want to play the
video because we're not here to play
shock content but it does look like a
kick but I I I will play a little bit I
won't show any the aftermath because
it's gruesome but the first thing I
going to do is I want to show you this
Jack pic has this tweet in the article
he says read this to the end let's read
it
so this is a post I believe that was on
uh Reddit and it says to all the people
calling Matt pet grave a murderer if you
seriously think Matt petgrave murdered
Adam Johnson go f yourself the guy was
balling his eyes out on the ice and in
the dressing room and probably still is
right now he's going to have to live
with this for the rest of his life and
the last thing he needs is people
calling him a murderer the claim that he
purposfully kicked his leg up has some
Merit and is a possibility but to say
that he meant to seriously hurt or kill
Adam Johnson is pathetic and disgusting
if he did purposefully put his leg out
he did did so to get in the way of or
block Adam Johnson from making progress
as the puck carrier not to slice his
neck open his foot clearly clipped the
skate of another player causing him to
lose balance so even if he did kick his
leg out he had very little control over
where his leg was going now notice they
say it has Merit that he raised his leg
but he didn't intend to do it perhaps
the man pet grave was balling his eyes
out because he did try to kick this guy
didn't mean to kill him but did right so
uh like teenager is joy riding in his
car and speeding
and then he crashes into someone killing
him is he crying his eyes out yes the
woman in New York City the young woman
she pushed an old lady old lady fell
over and died did she cry in court she
sure did mhm does that mean that these
people are innocent no so we have uh we
have this
video and uh let me refresh it see if I
can try and I don't want to play too
much but I'm really wants to play it all
uh let's see if we can pull it up and I
don't want to play too much but I want
to just scroll through you can see right
here this is Matt pet Graven red
highlighted and this is Adam Johnson and
then you can see him he lifts his leg up
there's no reason for him to raise his
leg like that in fact if he's losing his
balance that's the last thing he's going
to want to do yeah he raises his leg up
right there you can see it and then hits
this guy in the neck but uh not
something we normally talk about but
this is basically the biggest story I
think right now yeah it's like the only
thing anybody's talking about and it's
it's like it's causing a lot of uh uh
conten just debate and uh as someone who
doesn't I played hockey when I was
little so this was like it looks like
murder to me yeah I mean at least like
an intentional manslaughter charge or
something like that because I've played
hockey well well enough to know that
like if I'm in the position he was in
why would I be lifting my out my my in
this case inside leg that high there's
just no there's no reason to maybe Adam
Johnson was leaning down and that
brought his neck in connection to like
the blade but still everyone that uses
skates knows that skates are sharp
probably hasn't sharp too he's playing
professionally or amateur I don't know
it's Pro yeah yeah Pro stuff I mean this
guy knows there's no question people are
pointing out that the the guy who did
the kick has like the most penalties but
I don't know I don't it's it's European
hockey so I don't know anything about it
European hockey uh yeah they get the
penalties for just using the wrong
pronouns it's crazy that's right that's
right that's Europe straight to jail
straight to jail straight to hockey jail
I don't know about murder but mans
Slaughter reasonable nope and this is
what really this is one of the things
that got me like okay we're going to
talk human event has the story
manslaughter would be like you're
speeding uh no actually that would still
be like a negligent homicide which I I
the law is very by state I think
Illinois has negligent homicide and
that's like if you're speeding in your
car and you hit somebody and they die
manslaughter is usually like you're
going too fast for the conditions but
you're going the speed limit you slip SL
hit the brakes spin out of control hit
someone and kill him and then they say
you could have avoided this manslaughter
is usually like someone died as a result
of of you being irresponsible yeah right
whereas negligent homicide is like
you're you you you may have been
committing a crime you were speeding but
it's not like the most serious thing in
the world and then in this instance if
dude was intentionally trying to kick
the guy that's Grievous bodily harm
murder yeah if you intend to if like
that that woman in New York she shoved
the old lady MH yeah she she's going to
prison for 8 years that's it eight year
eight years that's it she shov the lady
on purpose I'm sorry woman pushed an old
lady on purpose on purpose and she died
and the old lady fell down hit her head
and died and so they're putting young
young woman in prison for 8 years she
should not be going to prison for eight
years for that okay I I didn't see this
one I'm not sure shoving someone is
barely a misdemeanor okay this this
woman in New York who did it oh it
wasn't into the subway she just shoved
her no no no she pushed her on the
sidewalk oh okay I thought she was cuz
in New York they're shoving everyone
into the subway like you go in the sub
you're getting pushed into the sub I can
see I can see your confusion on the no
she pushed the old lady on the sidewalk
the old lady fell down oh okay okay and
then she was like I didn't mean to kill
her I just pushed her and so they gave
her eight years just for that now this
dude kicked the guy in the you know was
trying to kick a guy and he's wearing
ice skates that's murder second degree
murder intending to cause bodily harm
that results in
death I mean I just can't be imagin
being anyone that was on the ice that
day you know what I mean I mean every
report that I saw said that the the guy
died on basically on live TV and that's
tragic the crazy thing is
on the 28th I was in Pittsburgh such a
great City heard it is a great City and
uh I was walking with Alis and my
girlfriend and I left my coat at the
hotel and so uh you know started drizzle
a little bit wasn't super cold out but
the drizzle a little chilly and I'm like
I should grab a light jacket or
something I don't actually have one I
have like a Crazy Snowboard jacket and
so there's a bunch of these stores and
they're all selling Steelers merch
Pittsburgh Steelers football and so I'm
like I'll just get like a Steelers thing
it'll be like a souvenir I'll grab it I
go into the store everything thing is
Steelers this Steelers that and then I
walk in the back and there's this gray
like waterproof thin jacket I'm like
I'll grab this and then as I walk up to
the uh uh the counter I noticed it's a
Pittsburgh Penguins jacket and I was
like oh it's a it's hockey I was like I
don't even know I don't even know know
what this is cuz of the offseason right
now I forget about this guy on that day
when I was buying that uh used to play
for the this guy used to play for the
Pittsburgh Penguins he's now playing in
uh in the UK where does he play for the
Panthers no no not the Panthers I'm not
sure but he's playing in the UK used to
play on the Penguins and the guy pet
grave is on a team called the Sheffield
Steelers that's so weird I just thought
that was kind of
weird that a guy who played in the
penguins at the same time as this is
happening I'm buying a penguin's jacket
by accident at a Steelers store a fan
store and the guy who clipped him in the
neck played for the
Steelers I don't know man I don't know
what do they think they're going to do
anything we think they're going to do
anything about this yeah I me oh I mean
dude the UK nah they're going to
investigate him and they're going to let
him go and they're going to arrest his
neighbor for very racist yeah yeah
definitely also it was led in the chat
here that he has 71 pound penalties in
11 games so is that a lot I mean 71 P
penalties is quite a bit you're
definitely 71 and 11 games that's like I
don't not a math guy but that's like a
lot yeah that's quite a lot it's
numerous ones per game so it would be
interesting to see this go to trial I
don't know what the charge would be but
you know the defense obviously can argue
in a murder case you know he it was
accident he was on Ice he didn't mean to
whatever else and then the other people
have all these things to point with
already I mean if the if the media has
dug up his penalty record what else is
there I mean did these people exchange
worlds in the locker room there's all
kinds of avenues to pursue n they're
playing on different teams you I mean
any kind of argument to say this guy has
a history of being aggressive it it
would be interesting I don't think
anyone would be satisfied by the outcome
ultimately yeah it would be it would be
a lot of controvery well hockey is an
aggressive sport so most of them are
yeah pretty aggressive yeah oh yeah he
does play for the Panthers I think yeah
the Nottingham Panthers Nottingham yeah
yep I had no idea the UK did hockey not
at all Europe European League yeah no
clue yes a lot of so a lot of people are
saying you know Ian Mong says it should
be manslaughter at
minimum and uh I I can't believe
consquences it man manslaughter is just
like
no it's murder if you if you if like if
you attack
someone and they die you murdered them
mhm but I guess the argument is because
they're playing sports or something
there's a degree of like Mutual
understanding of physical bodily harm or
whatever yeah but they've got to
understand you you put your leg up
you're wearing a blade on you that's me
they do murder you have prove intent
right I mean that's part of it whereas
manslaughter is different manslaughter
is just he died he died because of your
action I don't know if they have the
laws exactly the same over there we're
talking about it through the American
legal system I don't know what their
legal system is over there I lived over
there but I never murdered or
manslaughter anyone so I don't know
experience you didn't have to experience
it for no I never had to so you know
what's crazy is a lot of people are
bringing up the Clint malaric is that he
pronounce his name malaric Mal yeah 1989
there's a video of this too he's a
goalie they crash into him and then he
got his throat slid as well and then
Serge was mentioned it's like the guy
what is the guy the guy runs up and then
like pinches the shut or whatever that's
crazy like I don't even know what you do
like I don't even understand how a
doctor could save a person who's
bleeding from their neck like what do
you do to stop that cuz the blood's got
to go to your brain man can they like
pinch it off and the blood just comes
from the other side or something that's
crazy you can if you can prevent it from
getting out of the body like if you
pinch and close it like if you can put a
basically put your thumb over without
actually you stopping all the blood I
suppose keep the flow going I mean not
not that I'm saying that it would be
easy or that it's something like a task
I could accomplish but a doctor I assume
but not on a hockey field probably in
that in that well they he did yeah 1989
guy ran up and like grabbed his neck and
pinched the artery shut and saved his
life this one I guess they didn't know
what to do now the doctors are all
affirmative action doctors hired for
there was no doctors there were none
they're they're on a hockey field and on
a hockey rank and uh uh they all just
like he's holding it mm and it's just
spraying and pouring out well and they
probably take that guy with his thumb in
the neck to the hospital with him they
can't pull his finger out until the last
second till they're ready to do
something I believe the the the guy in
the in the video with malach was like a
an ex uh ex combat vet from Vietnam so
he encountered before and was he was
able he knew what had what he had to do
which is a really particular thing but
man yeah God it's it's crazy when I see
these stories because people need to
realize a single sentence can save a
person's life yeah true I'm not saying
anything could have done here I really
don't know if you watch the video I mean
blood is spraying out so profusely
apparently within 10 seconds he
collapsed on the onto the floor and then
he was dead like he lost way too much
blood probably before they could even
pull the cameras away I mean that's the
crazy thing how fast this happened MH
but there's a lot of stories of people
who die and don't need to if people just
knew like a single sentence MH you know
so in this instance like what do you do
when someone's got a femoral bleed or an
arterial bleed or whatever if someone
just said to you the single sentence of
how to make a
tourniquet you could save a person's
life and it's the craziest thing I think
about this like the time span between
someone is injured 30 seconds later
they're dead they lost too much blood
and if you only knew that one sentence
they'd be alive right now that's scary
or if you had first aid equipment on you
you know it's not it's not hard to carry
a blowout kit I I got to turn a like
sitting under the table here
man that's cra
it's not going to do any do any good for
you know you're not going to do any good
for jugular but I always think about
these moments man there's there's a
viral video on YouTube it's old video of
like uh sports injuries that result in
paralysis and it's just like nightmare
fuel yeah but there's one video where a
guy playing basketball gets frustrated
so he bangs his head on the the bar
whatever you call it the bar that holds
up the hoop oh God yeah he's just angry
he's like oh and he hits his head and
then he goes rigid and falls over
paralyzed forever yeah forever God yep
cuz it like he hit it and it like hit it
it got hit something in his neck and
then his neck went out and then he fell
down and he was like that's it you can't
move there's that crazy video of that
girl trying to do the milk crate
challenge oh God they're doing that kind
of sh she falls down and then she's like
on her her spine it's like no the one I
saw was this girl was at a bachelorette
party and someone pushed her into a pool
I think it was the bride and then she's
paralyzed from falling in the pool she
hit like the edge it was like an above
ground pool and she hit the edge of it
wow what do you do from that I can't
remember if she's paralyzed or she died
but it was real really bad like these
things that people do accidentally can't
have extreme consequences that's where
like with the with the hockey video I I
think he probably intentionally kicked
his leg up but was it intentional like
I'm trying to kill him or you're not
you're not going to kill someone on
camera in front of all those people you
know what I mean if if you're angry at
him you want to go kill him he thought
he was going to kick him so yeah cuz it
makes sense the pads you're wearing in
hockey get cake right here would not be
life ending but I think he probably was
leaning too far forward he's like it's
you're on Ice you know I don't know what
happened he leaned too farward and he
connected with the neck and that's man
that's how it's all it's all it's going
to happen one cut that's crazy I feel
bad for the families to be honest like
they're having to watch everyone
speculate about all this both sides true
on air like that's just it must be awful
to be going through this right well I
guess I guess the question of
imprisonment and criminal charges is
what are we trying to do what is the
goal did this guy Matt petgrave
intentionally kick Adam Johnson to kill
him I don't think anyone thinks petgrave
was trying to kill the guy no so so so
how is putting him in prison serving
anyone anyone's goals it makes the PE
the family of Adam Johnson feel better I
I I I don't I don't know if that's the
the appropriate means of how we spend
money on our taxes I mean great it's the
UK I get it but thinking about in the
United States like I was talking about
that that woman who pushed the old lady
and I'm like why is she going to prison
for eight years she pushed an old lady
she'll never do it again she's probably
traumatized yeah so what's the point of
of prison it's to make the family of the
old lady feel better because now she's
being punished for 8 years well that's
going to destroy her life I don't think
that's actually fixing any of the
problems perhaps the idea is we'll send
a message they want to make an example
so that everybody knows that if you push
an old lady and she dies you're going to
prison like this lady and then it's just
like you're sacrificing one person for a
message to be sent to everybody else I'm
never a fan of that yeah I think it's a
fear of uh people who exhibit somewhat
violent tendencies how do we manage that
I mean think about the guy and his name
is sing my right now who uh Daniel Penny
had in that choke hold on the subway and
then he had this consistent history of
attacking people on the subway didn't
kill anyone as far as I know but on the
other hand caused very serious bodily
harm broke a you know an elderly woman's
jaw different things like that he had a
consistent pattern of violence and there
were minimal you know interactions with
social workers and the criminal justice
system and ultimately you know he was
once again in a position to be dangerous
and violent when he ultim no Daniel pery
he did a great service that day yeah I
mean it's it's just a question of you
know what what is the point and role of
the criminal justice system and you know
you don't want to you don't want to
punish people too harshly who have
learned a lesson on the other hand we
know that there are people who escalate
in their violence over time currently
the criminal justice system is to uh
manufacture the proper opinions and to
punish people for having the wrong
opinions and and behaving in the wrong
it's a joke you have CVS they have
pictures in in DC on H Street they have
pictures of the toilet paper roll so you
can tell the people the brand that you
want but they don't have the actual
toilet paper out because it'll be stolen
so we're talking about a criminal
justice system like that let me pull let
me pull up this story we got this from
uh NBC bay area Alam County DA Pamela
Price's work laptop stolen from SUV in
Oakland the sources say that's right the
da in uh in the B one of the Das in the
Bay Area who uh apparently softon crime
is now the victim of softon crime
policies this isn't the first one I I
just I just story last week about the
New Orleans Soros spack da who was
carjacked I think with his mom good yeah
well I mean it's not good it needs to
happen yes but but they want it to
happen yeah well then good that it
happens to them because they need to
learn they need to I have no mercy on
these people I I I see what you're
saying right and we laugh because of
Shad for but the problem is the Alam
County DA is probably laughing with you
do you think yeah absolutely they
intentionally do this and what happens
to them they go it worked we did it we
won we have destroyed this city yay and
then what happens is conservatives are
like haha great we agree and they're
like these idiots are agreeing with us
these people are destroying our once
great cities and conservatives are
laughing along with them what are we
going to do about them though that's the
thing yeah nothing unless the
populations decide that they want to
vote these people out this is going to
continue to happen and it's it's been
going on for the better part of 10 years
it didn't just it happen overnight these
these Das and stuff they've they've won
mult elections they've got their their
administrations well entrenched into the
the local areas and until the population
decides I'm tired of it that that it's
not going to change and not for nothing
but your average person that has kids
and a job that doesn't pay attention to
politics all the time they don't really
pay much attention they don't know
what's going on they're not aware and
when you tell them i' I've had the
experience myself I'll tell my friends
that are left I was just in California a
couple weeks ago I'll tell my friends
that are left leaning about things and
they just don't believe it they're
astounded they have no idea and I don't
blame them because look you got a family
that's the most important thing in your
life you got kids that's the most
important thing in your life I get it
but you do have to be aware of what is
going on in your own municipality we've
got a guy in Philly named Larry kassner
he's a disaster nobody even knows his
name they don't even know his name this
guy has turned the city in into a
complete disaster not that we were ever
great it's been a disaster since I've
been born but right now what we have you
can't even go downtown anymore and this
what was this woman doing with a laptop
in her car visible by the way how stupid
this is how stupid these people are who
knows I it's it's it's it probably was
not visible who knows uh because they
smash out so what people are doing now
in the Bay Area they're leaving their
their the the the back Gates of their
Vans and SUV is open and they're they're
leaving the doors open yeah I why I
heard so that the criminals won't smash
out the windows to come and so if the
doors right so they walk up to they walk
up to any car with nothing in it and
they'll smash the windows out and then
check the trunk and then leave that's
why we got the Second Amendment we and
we seeing this taking place throughout
the United States and all of these
Democratic run down districts people
when you keep voting for the same people
and you are expecting a different
outcome it's not going to happen that's
the internet definition of insanity
but like like like Phil Phil Phil
mentioned these people don't know and uh
you know I can say proudly that uh the
past few holiday Cycles I've encountered
many people who engage exactly as as
Phil said you'll say something like yes
X happened and they'll go that's not
true there's no way and then uh this is
two years ago and last year they're like
you know I read that and then I was
reading this thing too and it's like
people are starting to realize Ian was
mentioning this a couple weeks ago that
whenever a crazy story comes out he
immediately has to call his to make sure
he gets the information to her before
the mainstream media can put some cover
up over it is his own breaking news to
his mom yeah mom you're going to hear
the story here's the link it's from this
article they're going to come out and
they're going to say something and then
he's like if I don't if I don't tell her
she'll believe some crazy nonsense later
on mother watches that stuff and the
things that she believe she's probably
watching this but she's never watched
the podcast before I know that much but
you know the things that you believe if
you only get your news from the
mainstream media it's unbelievably sad
how misin these people are and willingly
willingly it's all out there we know it
we found out to some degree to some
extent I agree with you there I'm I harp
on uh Barack Obama in the 2012 I think
it was ndaa that repealed the smithm uh
or that had the smithm modernization ACT
essentially what it what it said is that
for since the 40s the federal government
wasn't allowed to propagandize the
American people essentially they
couldn't produce materials for
dissemination inside the United States
and in 200 I think it was 12 um the
smithm modernization Act was part of the
ndaa that Barack Obama signed and it
happened just at the time that the
smartphone was was coming into it was
getting into everyone's pocket and
social media with the like button was
essentially the most powerful uh mind
control tool ever invented and so you've
got people that have that are in in uh
in the tech industry and stuff like that
are producing these
that draw people in and people love to
use them and the federal government is
given free reign to feed these Tech
Industries tech companies and whatever
information they want and the media and
the tech companies do it willingly there
was no need for payoff or anything
because what they what the federal
government offered was access if you do
these things you scratch my back I'll
scratch yours and that was the beginning
of the the uh the tech companies in my
opinion becoming a part of the m milary
industrial complex and you never hear
the Republicans who are supposed to be
on our side about the propaganda stff
you never hear them talk about that act
and you never will there's there's one
candidate in Texas Caroline Kane only
person I've ever heard bring it up I'm
pretty sure that there's a guy running
that will talk about it uh the AK guy
brenon I forget bren's last name uh but
uh but he'll talk about it he mentioned
it um but it's something that people
need to know the fact that the federal
government is not only allowed to
disseminate IM information into into the
population but is doing it in
conjunction with tech companies that
have the ability to literally control
people's opinions right people will
behave in remarkably different ways if
they get likes or they get you know
approval from their friends and that's
exactly what the like button does it
gives people that little dopamine hit
and those
small those kind of small dopamine hits
that are not something that that is a
big deal it's a little bit all the time
It Go flies under the radar and it has
had a massive massive impact on the
population people talk about how in like
2012 13 everything seems so much crazier
now than before that and and you hear
that people my age talking about that
all the time you know and I truly
believe that it is because prior to 2012
2011 you didn't have the kind of
consistent propagandizing from the
federal government I don't I don't think
so I think you said to yourself with the
with the algorith algorithms that's
private sector that's not that was
before uh uh the the the repealing of
this act and the US government has been
propagandizing for a long time a lot of
the stuff that we see leaked from
Wikileaks for instance and from other
hacker groups around that time show they
were doing this well before and I think
what what they ultimately did with this
was more overt it was The Simpsons esque
super Lial where they just launch these
american-backed
foreign uh uh SP like media companies I
don't think that repealing this
propaganda Act is what made everything
crazy I think it's social media and the
internet and that's why the '90s was the
last decade right like every every
decade is is easily discernible except
for the 2000s and Beyond it's a big mess
yeah and it's because the internet
fractured Global culture American
culture and has continued to I think
it's going to be rebuilding itself
though I think uh it it shatters into
all these different Pockets where people
start listening to very specific things
specific people and you no longer have
uh I said I said this 10 years ago I was
at a conference I said Fame is done
because of the internet and I was like
you're going to have famous people but
it's not going to be like you know
actually fil I were talking about this
like Metallica the biggest band ever
yeah but it's because there were there
was a period where culture was more
unified yes and there were fewer
channels to get access to music
Metallica being the best got everybody
but now there's probably a band very
very very good very great music but they
have a much harder time reaching as many
people because no longer straight top
Town broadcast tower it's more even out
everything is Niche now but I'm I'm I'm
kind of thinking that things will start
to rec coales again they'll start to
come back together for a combination of
reasons one people are like power
naturally does this and so we're seeing
people want to be like each other so
there's Trends and they want to follow
these Trends but more importantly the
powers that be are desperately trying to
Cobble back together the broadcast tower
so they can have singular control over
what people
think yeah and we see that a lot you
know some like the elderly population
they stay home all day they watch the
news channels all day and they believe
everything that's being shown on the
news you know they don't search for any
type of education to dispel anything
that they're seeing on the TV so that's
why it's so important that you talk to
them you know help people understand
that everything that you seeing on the
media isn't necessarily true cuz the
ully in particular were raised in a
different era of information right I
when you only had radio had like
channels it's very different not that
you should have believed lie way could
lie way better then but also there was
very few Outlets to challenge it and now
we have a lot of ways to challenge
information in fact it can happen so
rapidly it's often hard to keep up with
and I think that's where uh people who
are not as engaged either because of
their age or because of their lifestyle
sort of get lost they can only get the
headlines and that's not enough I've
talked about my uh my show idea a couple
times here which is more like like a
half-ass show idea because it's like
never going to get made but the idea
being that in the future I'll give you
the very quick version the planet
basically is post-apocalyptic there's
one city left it's the last City it's
relatively big and no one has any idea
what happened to humanity or how
civilization collapsed long story short
it turns out all of humanity still
exists they just are in underground
bunkers in the metaverse plugged in
plugged their brains into the neuralink
and the reason why the last City doesn't
know this is because they they consume
information in a dramatically different
way the idea for that is basically
because it's happening now older people
don't know how to use I'm not saying
they absolutely don't I'm saying most
old people don't use Twitter don't use
Tik Tok or Instagram and get their
information only from the authority
figures on TV so they are living in
Bubble World and when you go to them and
you're like hey here's a thing that's
true what you're believing is fake
they're like I don't know what you're
talking about you're like let me show
you the tweet I don't know what that is
you may as well be going to someone and
being like you don't know what's going
on with Joe Biden because you're not in
the metaverse plugged into the neuralink
and getting the information down oh
there it is new information proving his
corruption and then they're like what
information yeah he took $200,000 how do
you know that it was wired right to my
brain if you were plugged in you'd know
it too I don't know how to plug into
that stuff I'm going to turn on CNN CNN
doesn't talk about it that's basically
the gist of the the story I was making
up is basically see that what we're
seeing now with how people consume
information you can go to your friends
and family and there's a reason why your
older relatives and family holidays
don't know these things and don't
believe you because they're not plugged
in the same way all of you are I mean if
you're watching this show you are
plugged
in yeah you're you're engaged in a
different way and I think that's one of
the interesting things that we'll see
happen with definitely Millennials
probably gen Z is that they are ra I
mean I know more and more people and I
wish I had the data with me on me to be
to to to prove this but one of the
biggest changes culturally is uh that
people don't have cable anymore there
are tons of families that just don't
have it you know college students who
are getting their first apartments or
young adults whatever they don't get
cable because they only need Wi-Fi
because they stream everything anyways
uh there is a complete disconnection
from an entity that used to have access
to people maybe that's good on the other
hand they are relying on a very
decentralized way of getting information
and that could also be bad I mean this
is why well kind of I mean it's it's
centralized too that it's on Tik Tok
it's on the on same platform it's no
longer the internet anymore like our
millennial generation grew up with the
internet and going to different sites
and stuff now it's on platforms these
platforms have organizations Behind
These pages yeah so it's another
centralization of new source which then
unfortunately leaves it really
vulnerable to this sort of like top down
control media narrative saying like it's
going to be one way or the other and
this is the only way to hear the story
so big big agendas we got this uh this
story London and UK Street news Pro
Palestinian activists throw live mice
into McDonald's I kid you not here's the
video
clip all right we'll turn that down and
you've got the free Palestine they've
got the
like seriously don't do anything like
this because dude what like this so mean
to the mice let alone like the illegal
the ille illegality of doing this look
at this this is pro Palestinian
activists walked into a McDonald's this
is in the UK they say rats and
McDonald's but these are clearly
mice God help that's so messed up dude
hell no those poor mice like those mice
are probably going to get killed now
because for no reason they should be fed
to a snake or something and they want
you to do going to do it in Starbucks
too
what is the point of ruining the
community that you live in they say hold
on look at this they they say Starbucks
they say uh target target targeted
boycott the big three start by
boycotting these brands that are
directly involved in supporting the
Israeli apar tidde Starbucks McDonald's
and Disney
Channel well okay how does that help
their cause I mean who's going to say oh
yeah they threw rats we got to be on
palestine's
side and it's disruptive to business I
mean that's the point right you release
mice into a restaurant they have to shut
for a couple hours McDonald maybe not
don't McDonald's the thread that runs
through a lot of the the protests and
stuff like that is just anti-western
anti- capitalism so the whole
Palestinian thing like the Palestinians
are fighting the Israelis the Israelis
are are generally looked at as a western
democracy this is an attack on
capitalism they think or they would
probably consider an attack on
capitalism an ATT an attack on Western
consumerism an attack on actual Western
uh you know things that are in the west
you know so the the the fact that the
left is kind of a monolith now I think
that that's part of why it's playing out
like this and nothing will happen to
them in London and they know that London
is a disgrace the entire UK is a
disgrace what they let people get away
with that's why it's such a disaster
over there but you mess all of the
amount of raping the attacks the they're
literally arresting people for qu for
silently praying outside of an abortion
yeah several times there's a lot of
those videos multiple people get
arrested for literally standing there
and not social Med post too I mean there
are many people I knew a woman over
there went to jail just because she used
to go and protest in hide Park she used
to not protest but you know Speaker's
Corner which was supposed to be all
about Free Speech they arrested this
woman I know two times because they
didn't like her speech well speaker
Corner that's the point of it the whole
of Europe has become woke and that's why
they're being taken over that's why the
whole place is being destroyed you and
they want us to pay for their defense
yeah sure we shouldn't be giving them a
thing we should be out of NATO we should
let them just do whatever they want out
of NATO out of NATO get out get out let
them f for themselves you want to be
woke you want to be all into that crap
get out this is going to be really
interesting though as uh uh that's
basically what's happening is the
American people are basically fed up
with the failures of Europe and US
footing the bill and we've been footing
the bill since basically World War I
yeah and why they're they're letting
themselves become invaded they are
allowing even Italy Spain the all these
countries they get people over from
North Africa all day they come in they
have no respect for the culture of
Europe no respect for the history of
Europe they come in they rape all the
women like it's their job they do all
these awful awful things to the
communities they take over entire towns
what are we supposed to do bail them out
when it turns hot when it gets into a
real the issue is the the unchecked
immigration and these videos of people
landing on on and rushing into the
country I don't think the issue is
immigration no not immigration as a
whole but these are people that nobody
knows who they are somebody came with a
goat yesterday on an NGO boat into Italy
there was a video of well could have
been an emotional support goat it's an
asylum Seeker What do you talk an asylum
Seeker with his it's not an aslum
partner or whatever you want to call it
goat is not seeking Asylum that's true
no the goat well the goat might be
because God knows what's happening to
him on that boat but goats goats are
based and we like goats and the issue is
this is where want to be careful of not
conflating if there's a legitimate
Asylum case and the issue is no no no no
no no no no no no no they're not asy
they're not asy them no they're not the
these people are economic migrants as
per the UN yes so when people are like
like I think it's important to tr the
distinction specifically because it's
the argument used by the left to justify
having no border security so so AOC
specifically saying they're legal asy no
no no the people that we're upset about
are quite literally the people who are
criminals not the immigrants and the
Asylum Seekers who are either
legitimately coming here because they
love this country or they they want to
seek opportunity and they're find the
paperwork the people that are the issue
are the people who are breaking the laws
coming here and then Contin cartel
members etc etc and then they're going
and committing crimes right right and
it's an insult to people who do it the
right way and the left is trying to make
sure that when we talk about it it's one
group yes instead of completely separate
groups of people right if people really
liked as for as for Europe you know the
is they're not having kids none yeah
there's a I don't know if this is true
people are saying that Italy hasn't
recorded a birth in a few months like
this I don't think that's true what did
they say Italy hasn't recorded a birth
period in three months oh please I don't
know if that's true no that's definitely
not true I no but there's but when you
look at the uh fertility rates I talked
about this last week in the US and
Europe they are collapsing right and and
it's it's it's it's not just like oh
look they're down because we've no they
were down before it's worse now yeah
it's worse but I will say the path
towards uh uh winning the culture war is
actually really simple at this point too
it's just anybody who wants to win just
needs to have five kids yeah it's a
long-term investment in the future true
this is true yeah but I don't think that
people I mean I think about this all the
time which is like we say you should
have children but that that Tide's going
to turn really slowly and I wish that
there were more ways to get people
engaged in in making a difference well
it's easy to say have children but you
can't get a house in this country right
now the interest rates are 8 who can
afford I mean how many children do I see
when I come to your food bank in your
ly they can't they can't afford five
kids right now I mean if they want them
to have kids they should put some
incentives in place look at Hungary
Hungary did a great job you have four
kids you don't pay income tax yeah right
right where's that policy the child uh
tax credit I think Biden Biden was
talking about doing that Democrats were
talking about doing it I think that's a
good thing yeah it's a bipartisan issue
because if our birth rate declines too
far for too long I mean we did see an
increase in the years after Co very very
slightly not enough to you know really
say the tide has turned but it should be
a bipartisan cross-cultural everyone
needs to be having more children and
instead The Narrative is especially on
the left well we can't have children
it's everyone agrees it's too expensive
but they also argue the environment the
environment can't take you're
overpopulating there's too much
pollution this that it's not true you'll
it'll be difficult to fight that
narrative and ultimately as much as I
would love it if just conservatives had
millions of children to eat ultimately
you need a lot of people including the
moderates on the fence who might hear
these arguments to have children the
problem is is it's very very much
perception and standards and people
don't want to live beneath the modern
standards and that's that I look I I get
it I can respect it but I don't know how
you can look at people who came to this
country on boats and landed on on
desolate Shores with their kids these
people were like imagine if imagine if
the the original Pioneers who came to
this country were like nah I can't have
a family cuz I can't afford Med medical
care a house uh you know insert insert
insert yeah no 20% of the people died on
the boats and they came here anyway with
nothing and now I know I know people are
saying yeah but like you can't even
build house back then you could like
build a fortress or like you could you
or you could build a little house
somewhere in the middle of the Woods at
least and people would work with you to
build houses and it's like you could
move out of cities and struggle and have
a 20% chance of death like the original
pioneers and colonists and then find a
look if you move out of the city and go
somewhere where it's rural where the
houses are really cheap and then you
start doing the work the physical labor
to build your house you have a 100%
survival chance but are people built
like that anymore that's the issue I
don't think anybody really but saying
saying that we're not built like that is
not an excuse as to why the people who
came before us were Hardy and more tough
more resilient and more more willing to
take the risks just saying like it's too
hard today I'll be like it was harder
back then I don't certainly you could
succeed I don't believe that that
there's a that money is the real
deciding factor like people's inability
to afford to have kids like I don't
think that that's the real deciding
factor um I don't know I don't know that
I have a strong opinion on what it is um
I think it's probably cultural and and
has to do with with their with people's
upbringing and stuff but you know there
have been a lot of times where or
there's a long time of our history where
people had a significantly lower
standard of living and they were
punching out kids like it was their job
so it's not that it's not that you know
they have to have X amount of dollars to
be able to afford kids when you have
kids no matter how much money you make
unless you're like really independently
wealthy you probably always feel like if
you had a little more it would be easier
you know and so really the thing is if
you want to have kids you go and have
kids that's what people do if people
find it important to have kids they
don't wait until they have certain
amount of money they want to have kids
they have kids yeah America's declin
inclining birth rate parallels declining
Community participation so it is
generally a turning away from the
building of any sort of uh social group
right I mean the family is not just a
social group but it is a core unit of
your community and you kind of make
decisions from there and I think
especially people look to one another
and so even if we can never put a finger
on exactly why people choose not to the
more people who choose not to more
likely the people around them also opt
not to have children there's a lot of
propaganda again look at that uh what's
that beast's name um H Handler Chelsea
Handler always posting those Tik toks I
didn't have any kids I flew to France
this week I'm so happy no she is happy
good for her I'm sure so I was looking
at uh 3,000 ft of land for the in West
in a city in Martinsburg for
$119,000 wow okay not a lot of people
have a lot of people probably don't have
$19,000 you can get a loan for it to if
you want to pay pay for it but you can
get an acre of land for half that if you
got to the middle of nowhere now here's
the question if you went and bought an
acre out you know 2 hours West of DC in
the middle of a field somewhere bought
the land built a a a makeshift little
Hut for your family your family was
filthy covered in dirt and bathing in
the swimming hole and you were eating
and hunting for food and then you were
slowly cutting Dr cutting down trees and
having your kids help you build your
house which is very small would anyone
consider that to be a reasonable
standard of living for people in this
country CS would be
the answer is no no I don't think CPS
would be there instantaneously not at
all because there's tons of of of
families that are completely neglected
and ignored and these children are left
to suffer I'm talking about parents who
actually taking care of their kids the
oldfashioned way they'd probably be
completely ignored but nobody wants to
do that right the idea that you would be
living in the wilderness basically with
no resource no electricity living off
the land is Unthinkable and unheard of
and that is the difference between then
and now back then granted you didn't
really buy the land you just went and
set up up somewhere where no one had a
claim right nowadays you have to
actually buy it so you'll need some
money meaning you got to you got to have
some savings but nobody's going to do it
nobody nobody thinks it's reasonable to
buy an acre of land and then start
building a house you know taking care of
their family or even more reasonably you
could buy probably five acres for
$10,000 somewhere far out in the middle
of are there jobs out there that's the
thing do you need a job I'm talking
about eating deer and eating eating wild
fruit and learning which leaves you can
eat so our answer ancestors quite
literally did this knowing like hey
winter might come we might die but
they're like we're going to hunt we're
going to we're and they had basic skills
but people today don't have this and so
again I think it is unreasonable to
expect anyone to do this but this is
creates the predicament when we say we
can't afford a house we're saying we
can't afford insulation air conditioning
clean running water all of these things
are part of the standard that we have to
maintain and we expect to maintain for
our families but no one's going to have
no one wants to have kids unless they
can maintain what is effectively living
like a space King by medieval standards
the idea that your house is insulated or
that you have running water is like the
Kings didn't even have this granted
Roman Empire had indoor plumbing my
point is as the uh we've talked about
how technology becomes necessity luxury
becomes necessity when cell phones come
out only rich people the wealthiest
people have them and you don't need to
have a cell phone but if you do wow now
cell phones are you have to have it
right you can't get a job without it and
these things cost money so now all these
luxuries have become necessities and no
one can afford to do it and nobody wants
to go and live back off the dirt like we
used to back in the day no I think it
would be impossible for people to over I
mean the people I know who do really
live off the grid uh very few of them
have a lot of children and I think that
there are a lot of reasons for that
right it it is the reason we have iPad
kids is because modern conveniences are
built into a lot of parenting nowadays
and it's not that it's bad or good
although it's not great and usually both
parents are out of the household now the
mother's not there with the kids anymore
right and to maintain a modern standard
of living you would need both incomes in
most fames you it's it's I mean people
are not getting by well it's it's really
and and another part of this is the no
fault divorces yeah that ruin the men
they have to be careful and then the
child support comes in and then you get
ruined and everything you built you get
screwed there's there's very the society
is not set up to incentivize it there is
not a lot of incentive for people to get
married and more in the United States
there's there's very very little
incentive um if you have if you other
way around there's a tremendous
disincentive yeah yes fair enough um if
you which is funny because like
statistically it Bears out that children
who are born to married families do
better right there's all sort of
benefits keeping the there's no cultural
incentive but actually if you look at it
marriage is hugely beneficial and so we
have to remind people why we had
marriage in the first place that there
was a good thing there's Mar marriage is
beneficial to to individuals to families
to people but all of the outside
incentives disincentivize marriage all
of the things that that our society does
the media disincentivizes it all of the
I mean social media yeah absolutely so
and and until we can remedy that I think
that we're going to continue to have you
know instability in in family
creation and in culture I mean again
family is at the core of all Society so
if the family is in why would the
society be stable that doesn't make
sense MH y it's very true I think at a
certain point you know someone super
chated talking about Japan for instance
population's going to dramatically
decline it's going to have very
interesting effects on global power
structures and then there will be a
pendulum swing in the other
direction I think you can say that as
well if you look at Japan they currently
have all of the younger people in the
like in our generation pardon me are all
essentially making all their money from
taking care of the elderly like it's
like the whole industry in Japan and
it's not sustain for long term yeah
they're not having kids they're too busy
with their jobs etc etc it's it's a
whole cultural problem
feminism when when uh when we eliminated
the female traditional role and had
women uh take on the male traditional
role right this is what ends up
happening ex very true this is the end
what are we like 50 years into feminism
a little more where do you say we are
it's not it's not feminism it's the
birth control
pill I I think it's one of the same
that's a component of it with no because
you can you can have you can have
feminism and have have the ideas all you
want but if you don't have the birth
control pill and people people just do
not have the capacity to behave the way
that they do now the free sex the free
love stuff that doesn't happen that
doesn't no big time that's abortion
maybe but I think I think that you
wouldn't get to the point where abortion
happens regularly if you didn't have the
pill the pill allows women to go to work
regularly the pill allows it a lot of
women it it stabilizes women go to work
if they were on the if they weren't on
the pill they'll end up getting pregnant
have take care of just allows people to
act like caral animals
exactly had a huge I I agree and so does
abortion but there are a lot of women
who don't take birth control pills who
go to work it is it is a social Norm
that women must work that's it women
must get jobs and must take care of
themselves I but that that is a that is
a an effect of the pill that is not that
is not c a cuse
I I don't I I don't think so I don't
think you can say that they're related
in that way're they're two things that
are component of a similar thing but
they're independent of each other yeah I
also think that there during the birth
control movement you know there were
already women who were working who
thought well now that I'm liberated I
have my own money I want to be able to
behave different sexually I mean I want
a different life I think in some ways
women entering to the workforce encourag
them to get on birth control but I don't
think it's the other way around there
were all kinds of reasons that women
wanted or S thought that you know the
women's lib movement was attractive and
ultimately like I said with AI they pay
a price that they don't know what it
will be and the birth control pill is
incredibly dangerous it's overprescribed
in my opinion it does I think you're
right it does allow women to stay in the
workforce for longer but I think they
were already looking for ways out I
think there were arguments against
separating the family before the birth
control came on Mark was first step that
allowed women to behave as men I don't
think that's true sexually I think that
women already were there were there were
women's movements to them I mean this
was the whole argument with suffrage
right men can vote so we should be able
to do that that has nothing to do with
the birth control pill there's this been
going on for a long time is it good and
I think probably birth control expedited
it I'm no fan of birth control pill but
I don't think that it was the birth
control pill that opened the door for
feminism it was already there it was
just a ticking Time Bomb I think in some
ways feminism allowed people to be more
accepting of birth control pill because
they saw it as this Progressive choice
for women I I I agree with an Clair on
that the I looked it up the birth birth
control was invented in 1950 it was when
it was first introduced but like women
suffrage movement and women entering the
workplace was happening in the early
1900s these these Arguments for changing
in the in the in the roles happen with
industrialization and probably
population expansion and the security
State when women became secure they no
longer they they no longer need men in
the same way that men need women so you
know if you go back to well before
industrialization women are more
vulnerable than men men protect women
but once we eliminated the Bears the
Wolves the coyotes and the external
threats and had centralized police
forces now it's like the state can
function as the man for the woman in
general and the women can go do whatever
they want but now they need money to do
whatever they want right which probably
leads to the creation of birth
control yeah that that definitely
perhaps but we're going to go to super
chats for now so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net if you like the show if you
like all the crazy projects we're
involved in then become a member because
your work directly fuels this machine
and uh we're going to have that
uncensored show coming up for you in
about 25 minutes where you as members
can actually call in and talk to all of
us but for now we'll read your super
chats all right RJ McDougall Heim with
the first Super Chat saying yo Alpha
turkey unfortunately you were you were
not first he says first no second Isaac
however says thirst
correct for third and you are correct
you were the third Super Chat
congratulations Jason Dixon says hey Tim
can you please shut up the Discord we
are building community and we would like
to one day thank you in a voice Forum
please visit us uh yes see the Discord
server that we when you sign up to
become a member at
timcast.net sign up we just have that
gate because trying to keep out Bad
actors however the members have created
their own shows their own chat rooms
their own projects and so when you join
you're also part of that club where
you're hanging out with like-minded
individuals they're doing great work
they got pre-shows they got after after
shows uh it's really great stuff it's
crazy they're they're the most
productive worker bees I've ever
seen all right d babo3 says Alec Baldwin
coming to Steel citycon outside
Pittsburgh in December Facebook comments
roasting him hopefully he doesn't shoot
anybody he have he'll have be on his
best behavior coock production says
couldn't believe the amount of lying
Chen did in Friday's culture War also
I'd be totally down to have Dennis
Prager debate Scott and have uh and
correct him on his history on Israel we
can uh we can we can look into that
that'd be great culture War episode Will
Chamberlain says that he would debate uh
Scott Scott Ard yeah yeah okay all right
I think everybody wants Dennis prer
because it's like it's Dennis Prager you
know what I mean you know but that would
be really interesting and and and will
Will's very mild mannered yeah it would
I do not think it could possibly get
heated no Scott would get excited and
then will would just be like well you
know the thing is very calm yeah all
right what do we
got Raymond g Stanley J says Sean
Strickland out here playing 4D chess oh
man yeah dude we're going to talk about
this in the members only show so we can
get a little spicy with it but Sean
Strickland came out with probably the
smartest thing as as as it pertains to
the Bud Light UFC sponsorship that I
even think of and he hit it out of the
park yeah we're going to talk about he's
basically saying that budl is now paying
him to say everything he's going to say
and everyone else and you know what he
makes a good point maybe this does save
Bud Light because wait till you see what
he has to say he's talking about a lot
of culture War issues and being very
strong about it uh he said some things I
don't think anybody in this room would
want to say but uh the point is he's
pulling he's pulling in a very he's
pulling as hard as he get in the other
direction and forcing budlight to pay
for for it jts says get Sean Strickland
as a guest I knew as soon as I saw the
UFC story that he have he would have
something to say the guy is really funny
really bass and is actually a good
example of what a champion is that'd be
epic I mean I when I first we'll say
we'll save it because I don't want we I
we got to talk about his statement we're
going to talk about it's not family
friend well it's probably family
friendly but we're going to save it for
the members only we're gonna we'll get
spicy with it all right Brandon says
check out protests in Panama over
chinese-backed Canadian Oil Company
given large land and land stealing
rights huge fear the protest could
disrupt the canal and that China is
aiming to take it over they are uh China
tried building the Nicaraguan Canal this
is like 10 years ago and they would they
would have had to have destroyed a
massive natural aquafer to do it and so
it was ultimately abandoned but uh
controlling the Panama Canal is big
bucks
power all right Harry to says FYI your
channel always shows on my top row of
suggestions I had to scroll down a bunch
to find it it's never done that before
well here you go this is what happens
when uh you know we we call out these uh
these stories so make sure you smash
that uh subscribe button and that Bell
but also you can always watch the show
on the front page of Tim cast.com true
yeah it is always there on the front
page of
timcast.net
and uh it'll keep playing the sound and
you can keep listening oh that's great
Harry says I also uh didn't get a
notification I had to scroll a bunch to
find your show yep yeah I didn't get
notified together there po pay says
where is Ian is he okay I don't know G I
hope so there's no more Ian we'll take
we'll take we're so if he's not back by
Wednesday we'll take the sign
down and then uh and then we'll put up a
a Phill sign or something we'll have to
get one made there you go all right
where are we at Leaf Hagen says in
States Trump is removed from the ballot
down ballot Senators reps da Governors
Etc will all suffer greatly we're
talking county by county that's right
yep tremendous victories for uh for
Democrats that's the point yeah James
moaning says first stand your grounds
coffee is delicious well done second
what do you uh what do you want the
normal people to do you have the doj and
judges against non- demems you have
establishment against us and you have us
worried about effing cowboy boots repeat
effing cowboy boots hey we're going to
have a little bit of levity on the show
just because we talk about Ronda Sanders
wearing high heels doesn't mean we're
not saying don't get serious but uh what
you do is actually it it is relatively
simple the first thing you do you listen
to a show like this the second thing you
do is you give money to people who are
doing tremendous things and I'm not just
saying give us money I'm saying anyone
you support think you're doing a good
job Scott presler however and by
whatever means you can support his work
fund the people who are doing the work
to the best of your abilities one of
those things you could do obviously
would be would be become a member at
timcast.net
[Music]
views even when you think no one's going
to agree with you they might they
probably will you got to do it look at L
there you go she's doing it right here
donate to her there you go tell them L
your website I mean really we go to we
got to support candidates like you yeah
that's lever Spicer 2024 nope just L
2024 okay.com oh that's better one it
easier she's busy being on the ground
she know she does if you're a good
candidate you don't pay attention to
those things you pay attention to the
people there you go all right Nick Lee
says in regard to Republican chances I'm
an independent living in PA and every
other AD I see is democratic campaign ad
for positions down the ballot not one
from Republicans yep I will say however
uh I went to Pittsburgh and I have never
been recognized in any other City more
than I was in Pittsburgh and it was kind
of weird we went to a hotel and the
hotel all three of the hotel valet
recognize me we went to Rivers Casino to
hang out and I got recognized by by the
woman running the poker uh room and
several of the players in the poker room
walking down the street someone not like
waved I was just like wow it's kind of
crazy like I go to a bunch of other
cities and you know here here and there
but in Pittsburgh it was like everybody
knew I was and I wonder if it's because
of like Midwest sensibilities for Rust
Belt you know I'm from Chicago but I did
notice this is really funny at uh uh we
we were at the Pittsburgh was it
Pittsburgh University or whatever it's
called University of Pittsburgh I think
there you go and on this green
Transformer box I took a picture of it
it was like Brandon uh Tatum and James
o'keef are coming in their fascists or
whatever blah blah blah don't let them
come and the argument against them was
just like the stupidest thing ever it
was like James O'Keefe makes things up
and I'm like why would a college student
care that a guy makes things up on the
internet I mean it's like oh we have to
protest because we think a guy made
something up on the Internet who cares
yeah is he making up the videos is he
hiring like really well that's that's
their argument but the point is if you
don't know who James o'keef is what
about would you would you like to
protest a guy who made something up on
the Internet is appealing to you you'd
be like what nothing better to do every
everybody makes things up on the
internet I was going to say that's half
of their dream careers to be like
YouTubers who make stuff up and get
involved in all kinds of drama I'd
imagine I've heard Pittsburgh is an
amazing City I've been secretly lobbying
for a show there for a little while so
I've never been though so all right De
Bron says the 14th Amendment also
details the oath support the
Constitution that is not the
presidential oath yeah but it is come on
it says what is say to serve protect and
defend the Constitution so not now it's
just getting semantics but let's uh
let's presidential oath of office the
ability to preserve protect and defend
the Constitution of the United States so
if that's not support for the
Constitution I don't know what is you
know but uh there's an argument there
president is not included in that and I
think that actually makes sense the
argument I would make is that in 1876
they did have Southerners uh uh uh
Southern States run Democrats running
for office they were holding office and
so the idea was they were basically
saying okay okay like no no one who who
did at that point but these positions
are probably fine if they did not allow
the the one of one of these states to
have a president these people were all
alive and involved in the Civil War then
it would have just led to more Civil War
that was the point of 1876 so I think
that might be why they say yes to the
presidency but I don't know for sure I
don't know all right rabert G stanberg
junor says pbd was my favorite podcast
before my brother showed me this one now
y'all are tied in my heart was so
awesome seeing yall start to collab
we're big fans he he's fantastic he he
he stole the show when he came to Miami
well he's from Miami when he lives there
but when he he gave that speech about
tolerant Christians and like what you
have to do like you got to stand
everyone just stood up started clapping
and cheering and I was like okay like
what do we say now he nailed it but
that's the point that's why I say share
the show um word of mouth is the most
powerful way podcasts grow that's it
people are always wondering like how do
I get a big podcast and it's like Word
of Mouth someone plays a podcast in
their car while their friend listens to
it they like it and they share it
someone else says hey you should check
out this podcast it's really good that's
it commercials don't do anything none of
that all word of mouth that's why
Twitter SLX is so is so prominent so
powerful maybe we should um actually try
to promote our shows on
that yeah maybe maybe or uh you know if
everybody who watched the show shared it
with their friends would be the biggest
show in the world yeah easily there you
go but I will also add too that it's
fairly obvious that a large uh uh the
large portion of our viewers are are
fairly moderate leaning individuals and
most of you probably agree like we had
one individ individual saying they were
independent that tends to be what we
find as well and that's also going to be
interesting too we're getting we're
getting some more interest I think it's
interesting that Jen yuger wanted to
come on the culture War we've got some
uh other Democrat personalities now
reaching out to us and I think it's
because they're they know that this show
is not a hardcore di hard farri Maga you
know super conservative show it's like
kind of moderate with crazy characters
like Ian and the the actually the
example of Pittsburgh is interesting
because Pittsburgh is what everybody
wants to win right the Democrat
strongholds sure but if you get places
like Pittsburgh if you get more rural
suburban areas Midwestern I mean PA
especially just across the board
Michigan Ohio Wisconsin this is what all
of the politicians are desperately
trying to win Midwest
yeah so if people in Pittsburgh know who
I am and they're watching the show at
higher rates than other places we're
going to have every Democrat in the
world begging to come on and and try and
Pitch their case and they're going to
get roasted also means that the power
centers are shifting right instead of
left which is good I mean that was Matt
Gates's feedback after the first time
the second time he came on because the
first time he came out here and then he
heckled us when he came to Congress and
was like oh you'll come out to Lauren
boer's office but I have to drive but he
said I was amazed by how many just
regular people waitresses truck drivers
random people I met were like I heard
you on timcast
I don't think people realize that's
that's one of the strength of the show
that people listen to it Boomers Boomers
W was a lot of young people no no I'm
saying Boomers don't realize oh right
right right Tinky Winky 31 says don't
know how much hockey you Yanks watch but
in the 24 years I've played that's one
of the most bizarre plays I've seen the
way in which the back Checker reacts
makes it hard to give him the benefit of
the doubt check out the Clint uh malchuk
injury we did we we watched it before
the show and I used to play I used to
play street hockey when I was a kid with
my my friends like that was our sport we
play basketball or baseball we played
street hockey we played kind of a lot no
one ever got kicked with a rollerblade
no in the face yeah it's just like and
then all my friends who even rollerblade
now and we have roller blades and I was
rollerblading last year it's just like
foot never goes up like that why would
it it would throw your balance all the
way off right trying to kick I mean it
has skat are heavy I mean like you have
to want them to go up they the otherwise
natur really come down unless you're a
figure skater but he's definitely not
playing hockey no and he's the way he's
dirction he's turning his skates he be
learing in towards the left and his left
leg is the one that's going up so it's
just like
yeah let's grab some more Super
chats Johnny ft says the only solution
to the a problem is is a return to
analog pictures and video will need to
be accompanied by the original
Celluloid well sure yeah I don't know
man it's it's hard to decide welcome to
the Matrix you're going to live in The
Matrix that's it thanks I hate it here L
says just the heads up the US is halting
exports of small arms for 90 days as per
The Epic Times yeah that was from uh
that story was from last week so hope
you all ready for
war it'll be uh fun I meaness all all
the listeners to timcast like if you if
you're unless you're a new listener you
probably already have guns if you were
going to get guns we've been talking
about this stuff for ages and ages so if
you're a new listener I'm sorry
to go get more exercise your second
amendment rights today by contacting
your local FFL and uh you know that was
that was that's the advice I'll give
everybody when I first moved in New
Jersey I was trying to figure out how to
get a gun and uh good luck in New Jersey
so I went to the police and the police
lied every single time the police
station lied everyone I went to told me
something different they said it's it's
remarkable because I'm pretty sure
they're intentionally lying to people
the they were like oh yeah you just got
to fill out this form it's a form we're
like okay then go online go to this
website and put it in and I'm like okay
and then the website doesn't exist and I
was like what is what is going so
finally I did the simple thing and I
went to a gun store and I said what do I
got to do and they slid me a totally
different form and said fill that one
out and then bring it to the police
station and I was like okay and then oh
no no no I brought to a specific station
where they took a picture of me and then
handed me the uh New Jersey Firearms ID
card and then I was able to go buy a gun
in New Jersey so if you need advice on
what you want to do or what what you
need to do talk to your local Fally fire
armed uh federally licensed firearm
dealer go to a gun shop they'll they'll
set you straight yeah guns well yeah
when I moved to Maryland I called a
local shop and I asked them about it and
they were like here are the rules here's
what you got to do and I'm like cool
then I called West Virginia and they
were like come on in and I was like yeah
and they were like constitutional carry
you got a West Virginia ID you're all
good you got to do the federal federal
background check and uh there you go
when I first when I bought my first gun
at in New Jersey it took uh uh three
days wow I think it took five because of
the weekend but like there a 3-day
period where if the feds don't respond
then so they were just like okay you
bought it we'll let you know what they
say because you're on you're delayed and
I'm like okay this is dumb yeah it
doesn't it exist here too it's Federal
Federal so it's everywhere everywhere
basically stupid law yep basically once
yeah because it's like if you need it
you need it imagine you're a woman
you're getting like a man is coming
after you you need the gun because
you're going to get beat the crap out of
you left the house something or killed
you got to shoot that I mean come on and
then you got to wait 3 days you're dead
already you have to use reasonable Force
to defend yourself if someone is
expressing their intent to kill you of
course of course so for me dealing with
a guy trying to break into my house
right who was a pedophile and dealing
with death threats the police are like
good luck and they actually told me
seriously oh yeah of course in New
Jersey they said that uh uh if someone
breaks in your house you have to flee
and I'm like to flee that's New Jersey
Law mhm United States of America and I
said where where too Fleet to where I'm
in my house and they're like anywhere
and the argument it's the Communist arum
it's quite literally out of out of out
of the Communist Playbook wow you should
flee instead of having to take someone's
life because the argument is yeah okay
you would rather kill someone than stand
outside and it's like well I don't know
what's going to happen if I go outside I
don't know if they got someone waiting
outside for me and so what am I supposed
to do and they're like if you can get
out you have to you have to get Maryland
is is relatively similar and Oh They'll
arrest you in charge you the felony and
then tell you to prove it unbelievable
you can't defend yourself outside your
home if someone is threatening you
outside your home you have to flee into
your home and then once you're in your
home if they try breaking in then you
can defend yourself and then West
Virginia is if someone threatens you you
can defend yourself good it's a simpler
law it's much easier to remember yeah
that's how it should be although her's
manager is uh he lives in Long Island
he's a Jewish guy and so obviously he's
got family in in uh in Israel and stuff
and and he started buying guns maybe a
couple years ago or whatever and now
he's like thank God that I did because
the rigar roll and all of the the the
paperwork that you have to do in New
York you know it's crazy basically have
a gun insane you know yeah make it
impossible you know you never know when
you're going to need it so and it's have
it Florida is staying your ground so we
have the right to protect
ourselves y Johnny ftis as a doctor you
can olude one artery but still have
enough blood flow to the brain from the
other side right man that's crazy pretty
sure that M case he literally just
reached into his neck and closed the
artery yeah stuck his finger in the neck
stick thumb into it how in the hospital
too if you get it like if you ever get
like gunshot wounds what they tell you
to do is put the put the uh the
tourniquet on first and then just stuff
stuff Gau into the hole until the holees
hard I watched a video right I watched a
video of a guy treating explaining how
to treat a gunshot wound and he's
sticking his thumbs into it just gauze
until he says it becomes hard hard as a
rock yeah and then you put a bandage
over it and then get him to the hospital
that's what that's what I mean a blowout
kit like a a trauma kit like that it's
all it is is gauze a a bandage to cover
it up in a tourniquet so and that's your
that's the only thing you need to to
like fix most of your your gunshot
wounds unless you have something through
the lung where you need a chest seal I
think everybody should go to one of
these like basic survival training
things where you know Luke does the
Tactical training stuff I'm like I'm
saying like I did this uh hostile
environment training which is really
hard to get access to because everybody
wants to do it and they've limited
classes so it's typically only big
corporations and insurance companies
schedule these things but anything like
this I recommend why it's so much fun
it's not like you're there and they're
like listen someone's gonna no it's fun
you're hanging out in the woods and
you're basically role playing like so
when I did the hosle environment
training they would uh put you through
the scenario and then have you actually
be actors in the scenario for the next
group of people so it was just a ton of
fun you go out and it was like you get
to be a villager harassing a journalist
you get to be you know uh police officer
or whatever it was it was good fun I
recommend it and then uh you guys will
learn basic first aid and your kids
should learn these things too and then
one day you'll slip and fall and your
kid will save your life yeah it's
important I have a woofer cuz I was raft
guide for some years and I I'm surprised
how little people know about basic first
a it's kind of shocking on my on my
Twitter account on my Twix account I
just retweeted a basic uh primary how to
treat gunshot wound so take a look at my
Twitch account it's crazy um I watched a
video about removing arrows and they
would use
feathers cuz the arrows would have the
hook on the Ed and they would put the
feather over the the Barb and then it
would and then both and then you pull it
right out it's kind of crazy like the
these things if you're knew y you know
well like you said before if if you took
one class and it ever became useful it's
paid for itself 10 fold for sure you
have your life Tyrion says kateed artery
exanguination
happens in 5 to 15 seconds wow yep it's
really fast crazy that's basically you
know a better fut just says Tim you are
write a little first aid knowledge can
save lives maybe when Luke comes back
give him five minutes per show for first
a PSAs that's a lot to do a lot I think
maybe we do like one special upload to
the website where we talk about first
date or something yeah or honestly we
just direct you to somebody who's doing
that like luk put it on his Channel or
something like that I bet there are
viewers who already watch watch stuff
like guess like between survivalist
accounts and just paramedics who have
YouTube channels I'm sure there's there
it's it's crazy okay like one single
sentence could be mean the difference
between someone living or dying or
someone being paralyzed and not
paralyzed like I watched a video it was
out of Africa a dude jumps in front of a
car and what do they do after he gets
run over they pick him up and start
dragging him away and I'm like okay
that's they're breaking his bones and
they're they're cutting nerves and
they're doing all that bad stuff when I
had uh when I broke my hand I didn't
move it I just held it and the doctor
said that the way it broke it was really
close to severing a nerve and probably
making a portion of my hand permanently
numb or paralyzed yeah and like you got
to know these things I granted I didn't
do anything I'm just saying my hand
broke and then I was like ah it hurts
and I went to the doctor and he was like
okay we said this properly CU you're
really close to severing a nerve and it
was like kind of
crazy let's grab some more Super chats
federali actual say says I still can't
listen to HCB since I measured and was
at 7 in flat I was never
5'11 see I'm telling you guys the 5'11
is the default I don't want to lie and
say I'm six feet but I'm also not as
tall as I actually want to present
that's okay there's there's room in life
for all kinds of heights out there yeah
I keep saying I am 61 exactly whenever I
say I'm 61 it Run's like oh you're like
5'11 or whatever literally am you're
like pull out your T measure I'm
actually 6'1 I should start doing that
why not I'm 67 you're I believe you true
well you and Baron Trump are the same
height you guys make eyee contact I'm a
little taller than him um but I'm 67
because I told everyone here that uh I I
am and because I'm the boss they have to
agree that's all that matters it's part
of our contract also his lifts are crazy
you guys should see them there was a
good Super Chat that I want to read
before we get to too late and uh let's
see where did it go where did it go s
pretty good I don't know oh here we go
uh KO Shepard says Dan santis could fix
a bunch of His Image issues if he had
said I identify as 62
yep that would have been great that
would have been great answer if he was
asked how tall are you by Patrick B
David and he goes well identify a 6'2
they would have all laughed and he would
have laughed but he does not have it no
he doesn't he's like a takes himself way
too seriously I know I I mean maybe not
but he just doesn't know how yeah I
don't know you ever you ever meet
somebody who tries to joke and the jokes
just don't work and you're like bro
you're just being uncomfortable like you
don't have it you know Ron
should have been the VP Trump the Santa
ticket would have been amazing would
have been amazing and then he said uh no
all right we'll grab one last one here
we got Winston Alexander says took me
four months to get my New Jersey CCW
multiple background checks High fees and
for endorsements from non-family non-
Leos also police chief
interviews that's and that's and that's
only after the Supreme Court ruling
right cuz when I was there they were
like nope they said uh in order to get a
CCW new you got to be rich or famous are
you either of those and I said actually
I'm both they're like okay you're good
and I was like wow you know and then it
was still really difficult but that was
basically the argument same thing with
Maryland these states were like if
you're rich and famous you're allowed to
have a gun but nobody else and I'm like
okay well that's BS but we'll uh we're
gonna we're going to jump over to the
members only show and talk about Shan
Strickland UFC and budl light's
partnership and the things Sean said
getting spicy so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net member and we'll have that
member's only show on the front page in
a few minutes you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Joey do you want to shout
anything out yeah my Twitter if you want
to follow me is Joey manarino
us I'm L Spicer once again follow me on
Twitter and also that campaign donation
website is L Spicer
l224 I retweeted lever's website so if
you're looking to
real simple no e on that l l a v e r n i
Am uh Phil that remains on Twix I am
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
follow us on Spotify and apple music and
Amazon and Pandora and YouTube you know
the internet you can ask your Alexa to
play it if you have one which is
terrible idea you can ask your Alexa to
play you you should ask your Alexa to
play it Alexa play All That Remains
Chris burman's gonna be so mad last time
we did this okay what's what's your
favorite
song um new stuff there is yeah I mean
that's I can't wait to show you guys uh
I think that if you're into metal and
you want to check some All That Remains
out you should go check out two weeks
check out what if I was nothing check
out this calling those are our our those
are big hits those are the big ones of
the big Bo I mean two weeks is is is is
a masterpiece thank you I appreciate
that Alexa play two weeks uh now it's
playing some other like Al S I don't
know how to talk to Alexa because I
avoid her at all cost you say this you
say Alexa play two weeks by All That
Remains that's how you do anyone if
anyone's if anyone's Alexa actually
started because of that please tweet at
me so I I know I if that actually worked
it does it happens all the time yeah
anyway yes uh I'm Hannah Clair brimo I'm
a writer for
timcast.net
and Instagram it's the best you can see
work from me Chris Berman Cassandra
McDonald all kinds of cool people if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at hanac C.B and I'm on uh
Twitter at HC bro thank you guys so much
and serge is here I am indeed uh South
Africa as World Champs once again as we
rightfully deserve um go box bua uh
that's pretty much all I have to say to
guys see you in the after show we will
see you all over at
timcast.net
I